the dave ramsey show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i
am dave ramsey your host chris hogan
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author two times over
is my co-host this hour as we talk to
you about your life
and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight
two five five two two five
jose is in tucson arizona to start us
off this hour
hey jose what's up hey how's it going
dave i am a big fan of youtube
it was it's an honor talking to you guys
well thank you sir how can we help
okay so i just recently got
um i am signing up for life insurance
through xander insurance
and so i am no longer together
with my uh son's mother she is out of
state
and i did not want to put him as a
beneficiary
um so my question is i was listening to
you and you said that
trust are not really a good idea unless
you
have lots of money and it's kind of a
trouble
to handle them so i was wondering should
i have
my sister one of my siblings as the
beneficiary
and put them give them instructions on
my will
on how to provide for my child until he
turns 18.
no we do we do use a trust for this
situation but it's only formed upon your
death
and so upon your death uh you the uh
beneficiary
is the uh jose sons trust or whatever
you name the thing
okay that's the beneficiary on the life
insurance policy and then you
the tr you've already designed the terms
of the trust how the money's to be
invested how it's to be handled for
the good of him and you can set your
sister up uh as the trustee
who would your son go to live with were
you to pass away
uh he would go out of state with his
mother okay he is
almost four okay then yeah you would you
would you'd set your sister up as the
trustee
and then you can put all kinds of terms
in there right you sure can jose
uh you can control a lot and the reason
you want to do that is you know your
sister can be the trustee with clear
terms of what you're wanting
but you would also develop what's called
a contingency
uh trustee this is the person that would
be the backup if something were to
happen to your sister
yeah the successor trustee on that but
the you know so
you just you do your normal will and the
will would state that upon your death
a trust is formed and give it a name
each
trust needs a name um and uh
and it'll be funded by this life
insurance proceeds
uh and then you you change your will
when the child becomes old enough that
you would just leave the money directly
to
the child meaning like when he's 21.
right right okay so okay so will
and trustee
okay and if my brother would be the
backup
yeah that'd be fun um it's just someone
that you trust to carry out your wishes
okay and as long and they would have to
follow what my will
says to the letter right what the trust
says okay yeah and if they don't they
would be liable to be sued by your son
later because they're they're acting his
best interest
according to the terms of the trust for
instance when our kids were minors jose
that trust is no longer in our will
because our children are grown
but it was said if something happened to
both sharon and i we were married
of course at the time if something
happened to both of us that the money
would be left into a trust
for their good for the good of the three
kids in our case and it said
things like um the the money is to be
invested in four types of mutual funds
with a 10-year track record each growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international like we into our investing
so we knew that the money would create
an income then and then the
income off of the trust is to present
x number of dollars uh to the person
taking care of the child so you would
send
the equivalent of child support to your
uh to the boy's mom
okay to take care help take care of him
and then beyond that
uh we can take some of you can let a
certain amount be there out of that or
you can do it however you want to do it
and
figure out a calculation then we said i
i
you know the only time money can be
taken out of the trust other than that
is for a medical need uh maybe a
car when they're a teenager and then
college
and then when after college when they
graduate the money is the trust is to be
turned over to them the money and the
trust just be turned over the child
that's how
ours was set up but we were very
specific on the investing
and we were very specific on you know
what the money could be used for
and then it's there to support the child
in the in the
growing up years yeah you could have all
kinds of control from the trust i mean
you can set it up to where they get
certain money dollar amounts at certain
ages
uh dave i remember i coached the lady
years ago and she her and her husband
had masked the fortune around 5 million
and she determined that every two years
her kids needed to go
back through financial peace university
or they weren't getting their
disbursement
and it was just one of those things she
wanted them to constantly be reminded of
how to handle it the right way
wow and i told her i said you you can
rightfully put that in the terms
it's your money absolutely you can't do
that i didn't do that
and i started financial peace university
but there you go it's not a bad idea i
like this yeah
melissa's in new york city hi melissa
how are you
good good thank you for taking my call
i've been following you guys for a long
time
so thank you how can we help one
question question for you
my husband is retiring in the next six
months
um the mid part of next year he's been
at the same company for 35 years
he will be 55. um my question is they
are giving him
a two options either a lump sum payout
or pension payments
and we really are torn between the two
okay um
i know what we're leaning towards yeah
it's easy
it's really easy i say take the lump sum
exactly and you roll it into an ira
there are no taxes on it okay let me ask
you another question this is the
stipulation now this is what brings a
fine line
his employer the stipulation with the
employer is they will
we in order to get that lump sum we have
to
go through a financial advisor or a
financial group
of some sort we they've got to take cut
the check to that financial group
or that financial advisor whoever we
choose that's interesting
well that's that's what we want you to
do anyway because if they cut the check
to you they have to withhold 20 on it
and the entire amount becomes
taxable okay so we do want them to cut
the check
to your new ira is what it is it's
actually not
to the financial advisor but it's the
ira that the financial advisor
arranges and it's called a direct
transfer
rollover so how much is this lump sum
melissa uh
transfer sorry roll over okay um a
direct
transfer rollover yeah direct transfer
rollover okay
uh 1.7 million oh that's amazing
absolutely
thank you way to go oh i'm proud of you
we keep watching it very closely because
the better the market does
the bigger the payout and then he says
that if it goes up like
if it does go up more so in like
february or march
he's going to cut the deal right then
and there because
because we can't neglect you know a
couple hundred and eight thousand
dollars
yeah so he's gonna go and i think that
even if we've made 1.5 i still think we
would have taken it
you need to take it you need to take it
every time here's why
here's why when he dies they keep it
that's right if it's in the pension it's
a so
it's a 1.7 million swing on the decision
even if even if it's 1.5 take it take it
yeah it doesn't matter
if it's 0.5 take it because
it doesn't it it doesn't survive him
yeah
and you invest it get with a smartvestor
pro at daveramsey.com and they'll help
you do that direct transfer rollover
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
it's easy for us to all get bogged down
into finances
and that can really hinder your work
performance if you have something going
on in your personal life
i just remember this feeling of hoping
i'm going to make it
till my next payday am i going to get
the electric bill paid
our grocery money is gone retiring and
planning for the future was
nerve-wracking what's going to happen
when there's just no money there's
nothing there
so as we look at trying to create a
culture where employees can be
successful
being able to reduce that anxiety and
take control of their lives
is important and that's where the smart
dollar program really plays a critical
role for us
it's a teaching tool you're giving them
a lifelong skill set
whether it's getting out of debt or
budgeting or how to best prepare for
your future
there was something in there for
everyone i was really surprised by how
quickly i was able to start tackling my
goals
it makes work easier because i know i'm
working towards something i paid off
over 20 000 in debt this year i paid off
all of my student loans
expect to be out of debt by this year we
don't have arguments
the way we did before smart dollar
brought me and my wife together
now we can retire in the dignity the
stress of
carrying that financial burden is gone
we have truly changed our family tree
teaching someone how to be financially
responsible
shapes your entire life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys i'm george campbell host of the
dave ramsey show video channel
you know every day people from around
the country come to our lobby
to do their debt-free scream on air and
we celebrate that so much because we
know
what freedom from debt can actually mean
it means that people are free to do
amazing things
and live like no one else like jet ski
the great loop
or start a dream business or retire
early and travel the country in an rv
or maybe it's simply giving more of
their money or their time through
volunteer work
or ministry so here's the deal if you're
doing something entirely outrageous and
out of the box
and it's all because you're debt free we
want to hear from you
sharing your stories can encourage other
people who are making their way
along those baby steps just send an
email to daveonair
daveramsey.com with the subject line
live like no one else
and let us know what life looks like for
you now we can't wait to hear your
stories
[Music]
we're drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm
is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host this hour
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five dan is weather stands in
new york city hi dan how are you
hi dave hi chris how's it going thanks
for taking my call certainly how can we
help
uh well me and my wife will be having a
baby in
may of next year yay yeah
so basically i'm looking to get some
insight on
the best way and how soon to get the
baby set up
right now i just have jotted down in
front of me 529
opening an index fund in the baby's name
maybe putting the baby
as an authorized user on my credit how
soon
and of these things which one should i
go for uh
the last one never
they should never be an authorized user
on your credit uh
you can you can't form a 529
i'm sorry not as far as like you know
giving them access to their card when
they're older but just to
have them build credit i don't want them
to build credit because i don't want
them to go into debt
okay yeah i mean i do fully understand
your your views on credit cards
but i was just wondering if that was
like uh just something good for him you
know
no yeah you can't understand it because
you're suggesting it
okay okay yeah yeah yeah just wanted to
add no but for real
that fico score all it measures is how
much debt you have how long you've had
it the type it is
and the likelihood of them giving you
more so i don't want your kid to
i want you to grow up i want them to be
weird i want them to never know that
because their daddy had his act together
so as far as the 529 he has to be born
and you have to have a social security
number
so you can apply for the social security
number after the child is born
and then you can open the 529 or an esa
or an index fund in all cases
you will be the custodian and the
account is open in the child's name but
you're in control of it
uh and and so i would just start with
the 529 i wouldn't fool with an index
fund
uh let's go ahead and get the 529 going
is a good step and that's only if you
are
at baby step five i mean you're out of
debt
and dave i know i've heard you say this
but i want to reiterate for people out
there
if someone is in debt and they're
considering adding to their family
are you telling them to wait until
they're out of debt before they add to
their family
no i know that i just wanted you to say
that no again
we don't pick marriages or babies
uh based based on whether we're in debt
or not right
but in all cases whether you're married
or not
whether you're having babies or not you
need to be working your way through a
plan
to get out of debt and build wealth in
every case so
that's what we're going after and so in
dan's case it's pretty simple the only
thing i would do of the three things he
was asking about is i would do the 529
um and get that started if you're at
baby step five
the great news is he's obviously gonna
be a great dad because he's thinking
about all these things
he's intentional yeah and overall the
best thing you could do for the kid is
to get through those steps
like keep working the plan yourself and
don't do anything that puts you
going backwards at all that allows you
to make progress for yourself and this
baby congratulations dan
that's awesome mitchell is in
chattanooga hi mitchell how are you
good dave hi chris um so over
kovid i became an insurance broker and i
found art williams and through him i
found you
and my question is i've never been a
1099 contractor but i'm also still
working part-time
as a w-2 employee and i don't know how
i'm supposed to file for both or file
one at a time
i don't know how to start with that well
i'd probably get a tax professional to
help you do it but
it's fairly simple as 1099 you're
self-employed
and it is a uh it's a sole
proprietorship of a business
and so you have the w-2 portion of a
standard tax return
and then you just fill in what's called
a schedule c
and schedule c lists the x the income
onto 10.99 and any expenses associated
with your business
and uh the difference is called profit
and the difference is taxable
okay great that's all i wanted to know
thank you so much mitchell thank you for
reaching out because a lot of people are
going to find themselves in that
situation dave
uh when we at one point had 58 million
people unemployed
uh you know had people that are working
hustles and side hustles
and so you start to get these tax forms
in keep them in one place
but you want to reach out and deal with
a professional that can guide you the
right way
and i know our tax endorse local
providers
uh these are people that are in this
game all the time and they know exactly
what they're doing
yeah that's what i do mitchell i just
check on one of those because here's the
thing you may be able to write off some
things
that you don't know about and you may
not be able to write off some things you
think you can
and so it's worth it if you've got a
schedule c if you've got some
self-employed stuff to get a pro on
it just click elp at daveramsey.com and
those guys will help you get that done
but it's a fairly simple process
it's basically a little profit and loss
statement is what the schedule c is it's
your income
for your business minus the expenses for
your business equals the profit
or the taxable income of your business
ricky's in louisville kentucky hi ricky
welcome to the dave ramsey show thank
you hi dave how are you
right man how can chris and i help um
well i
made a mistake um and i had bought a car
i'm a little uh
i owe a little more on that it's worth
right now and i'm trying to figure out
the best option to
uh because i'm working on maybe step one
i'm trying to find the best option to
i guess get rid of the car without
having to like voluntarily surrender it
um so i can get a thousand dollar car to
roll with and save my
stuff up and pay my debts off okay
so how much do you owe on the car uh
right about eleven thousand and uh
what's it worth
um looking at kelly blue book it came
out around six thousand
did you roll over another car loan on
top of this loan
i did not how did you overpay that much
for the car
um i think i was just desperate to get a
car and i wasn't really looking
at uh what i needed to do before kelly
blue book was a trade-in value or a
private sale value
um it was a i'm not to be honest i'm not
100 certain on that one i think it was
uh i i can't tell you to be honest
you're looking for private sale which is
more than trade in
trading is what a dealer will give you
for it um and
so what is your income um
eight flux rates right now i'm on a 1099
income
but i'm averaging probably about 800 a
week on that
okay you know you're so far upside down
if this number is accurate
if that is the actual private sale
number
uh and you're five or six thousand
dollars in the hole
50 on this thing it's only eleven
thousand dollars
you're making fifty thousand dollars a
year i i would go ahead and just pay it
off
i would just put it in your debt
snowball and attack it and get it paid
off
because i don't think trading out of
it's gonna do you that much good if you
trade out of it
you're moving from a a five thousand
dollar car
to a one thousand dollar car and you've
still got a six thousand dollar debt
because you got to borrow the difference
that makes sense so by the time you do
all of that i just pay off the 11 grand
yeah just get it out of your life ricky
uh that's weird dave he had to have
looked at the trade in
i mean yeah i mean that just sounds too
far off
um battery got screwed well i mean i
don't know which it was
well that's possible it's very possible
but if listen you get your throw your
shoulders back
start to get intentional and uh you know
you're already looking ricky at ways of
bringing in money
you keep hustling just get this thing
out of your life but just take care of
it
right you want this thing to continue to
run so you can continue to make money
yeah that's exactly right open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five chris hogan ramsey
personality
is my co-host today here on the air
chris um i think cars
we don't talk enough about cars they are
um
i love cars i'm a car guy but they are a
financial trap
oh my goodness and dave not only is it a
trap but it can catch you
at the most inopportune time i remember
back years ago
pd is pre dave i did this stupid
i went looking y'all ever gone looking
you just go
browsing you didn't intend to buy but
you go looking and guess what comes home
it's like a pet and a stray dog it'll
follow you it followed me home the
vehicle came and a payment
so guess what i don't go look now i
don't browse so be careful what you look
at
because you can do some stupid i go to
buy that's right
there's a difference cash baby cash
is king this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
no what's the what's what's the question
for the day
all right so this whole thing has been
fun
i don't know if i can top this
conversation we've had but uh just
saying we usually do like a safer cave
question what's cool about this
is the viewers at home get to vote in
the poll that pops up
in the corner as well so i'm going to
ask you would you rather save money by
living in a treehouse like a super dope
treehouse
we're in an rv oh
the rv treehouse it can be like a
tiny house and a tree hmm or an article
they're both actually appealing to me i
might be a weird person
they are today too it's hard yeah cause
the the rv's mobile so i could go
different places
the tree house is just like oh i think i
think i might choose the treehouse
i'm going with it too as much as i like
travel dude
i love how i
tree house you got spiders you got birds
you got snakes
you got you don't have a toilet you
don't have like a tree i don't have a
hot shower
you know what i'm saying you don't have
you don't have a toilet in the treehouse
fancy tree
i'm talking like a nice tree house oh my
god nice tree
airbnb tiny house bro like oh you
talking about that kind of treehouse
air condition you have a fireman's pole
it comes down to your four-wheeler
whatever you got bathroom
that's the two houses but you can't
travel and you got a nice little forest
i mean but if you're talking about that
i'm thinking i'm telling you you're
talking like a tree house in the back of
the house no not a sand lot like oh yeah
i'll do i'll do the treehouse for real
i'll do that too that's kind of romantic
get the wifey up there
yes lord it's peaceful too it is and you
hear the birds i mean
you got some ac you got the higher
ground yes just in case there's people
you know one can just
i'll get a little nervous though because
what if like we have an earthquake or
something like that you know what i'm
saying you find some strong trees
have a cushion at the bottom just have a
cushion
you do need to have a cushion at the
bottom
falling a pool yeah hot tub whatever
nah man now you talking about drowning
bro no
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo justin thank you so much for rocking
with me today man
this was an amazing show i'm so
uh just uh proud of you and what you're
doing thank you thank you
for you know just representing um all
people well
especially us millennials man you're
you're killing it
uh make sure when you pay off that debt
uh make sure to uh text me and just let
me know so we can get you on the show
with dave
i want you to come and do the debt free
scream because your story is amazing and
i know dave
would love you bro we gotta have her on
if
cause hopefully here's my thing she come
what if he pay off his debt
what if he proposed
we wouldn't do that to you bro
drop that question you debt-free yeah
yes
yes y'all just said we love you sis
appreciate you so much
and uh yo you keep in touch man for real
thank you so much for all of your
inspiration and motivation i've been
following you for years now
and it's really helped to keep me on
track and and stay
stay on my p's and q's so i appreciate
you for doing what you do you never know
who's watching oh man i appreciate you
for real that's amazing
step one one thousand dollars to start
your emergency fund
step two pay off all debt using the debt
snowball
step three three to six months of
expenses
in savings step four invest fifteen
percent of household income
in roth iras and pre-tax retirement
step five college funding for children
step six pay off house early
step seven build wealth and give
people call my show all the time
complaining
about how awful their timeshares are
and i've been saying this for years
don't do it
what's going on out there that's content
allowing this industry to just continue
dave it's greed and honestly this isn't
going to change
until the industry decides to recognize
that they have a customer service
nightmare because of a terrible product
they're not taking care of their of
their customers which is why
we're flooded with calls every day
timeshare exit team is different i mean
we we
now have you know almost 20 000 people
out of timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
yes
if you need out timeshare exit team
is the team the only team
that i trust to help you schedule your
free consultation
by calling 844 999
exit or timeshare exit team.com
hey folks welcome back to the dave
ramsey show i'm will smith hanging out
with you guys here today
on the video channel and i want to
remind you guys we are giving away
cash all from now until christmas you
can enter every day for a chance to win
500 cash we're giving that away every
week and then right before christmas
just in time for christmas we're giving
away five thousand dollars
that's huge make sure you go to
daveramsey.com giveaway and enter for a
chance to win right now
alpha and jacint are here to do their
debt-free scream we just saw him on that
video on the anthony o'neill show
now they're here we're gonna hear their
story coming up right now on the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
on the debt-free stage right here in the
ramsey solutions lobby alpha and
jacint are with us hey guys how are you
hello
welcome where do you guys live las vegas
nevada
nice trip over to nashville huh well
it's good to have you guys
and here to do your debt-free screams
how much have you paid off
so we paid off combined uh 130 000
in three years 130 okay now explain this
to me combined
you were so we were not together i
started my debt-free journey
in 2017 and
then i met alpha a few years back and so
i finished paying off my 90
000 in may of this year and then he paid
off his
40 um before we got married that started
in january
okay and when were you married october
26th so we have two debt-free screams
yeah officially all right all right
alpha did she encourage you to get
started
tell the truth so to be honest yes how
it went was i i
you know when you're man you want to
throw things out to see if you can get
her to start thinking about marriage and
get a response
yeah and before i can even get the words
out of my mouth she says i'm not
marrying you with that
whoa so
it was more than encouragement it was it
was uh
inspiration it was a whole lot it was
changed my life a great deal
serious carrot right there dangling
right there
yeah man i'm telling you how did you get
so feisty about this money stuff
well you know i i had some life happen
to me
in about 2014 and then when i came to
in 2017 i said i a decision to make i
can keep going the way that i'm going or
i can
get back on track because i actually
knew being in debt was never a good idea
i actually saw
dave at central christian when i was
about 18 or 19.
i started the book more than enough and
got to the integrity part and i thought
it was so good i just stopped reading
the book
but the plan was in the back of the book
so
so i you know i got off track i didn't
have a plan got into debt
and then kind of came to in 2017 said
okay it would be really nice to be
debt-free
and then i thought when would it be nice
to be that free buy i was like well
let's see if we can be debt-free by 30
and so i made the decision and then i
started creating the plan because
in 2016 i only made 17 800 so i ended up
tripling my income
within the next year because of the
decision and the focused intensity
okay so let's break these down to start
with just you paid off
by yourself before you're married how
much over ninety thousand dollars
ninety thousand bucks and that took you
how long
three years three years okay and your
range of income during that time
from 17 000 to
over 60. wow and what do you do for a
living i'm a licensed marriage and
family therapist
and a whole bunch of other things very
cool
and your uh three uh your 90 000 was
what
student loans and credit card debt okay
very cool
and then alpha you paid off 40. i'm just
under 40. yes
and you did that in about just a few
months right correct uh from i started
in january and i was complete by august
okay so eight months all right very cool
and your range of income during that
time uh anywhere between 28
and then i ended making 65. cool and
what do you do for a living
i'm an educator and a whole lot of other
things as well okay
all right lots of side hustles with the
two absolutely yeah okay
very cool guys so that's the 130 000 is
the 90 and 40 combined
but they were done separately and then
we tie the knot you got married in
october
you said right correct wow very cool
this is so cool i'm assuming this
wedding was done debt-free
oh okay all right all right
you said never again she wouldn't marry
him
if he had that she hadn't getting
married all day i just want to make sure
you don't even need to check that that's
i'm proud of you too thank you seriously
i mean just the level of focus and what
you did
in the amount of time it paves the way
for you now
you know you've got opportunities in
front of you instead of debt and
obstacles
man amazing yes very very cool yeah the
snowball's rolling in the other
direction now
so watching the watching the account
stack up
is actually kind of amazing you know you
have to blink your eyes a couple of
times
like wait a minute now all the money we
were throwing on debt
is now ours four hours and now we you
know we hope to save to pay for
uh house cash so sure pretty ambitious
on this end you got it you can do it
okay now i'm interested a marriage and
family therapist
is in love and still draws this hardcore
boundary not marrying you
till you got rid of the debt why well
you know i
i really wanted to be weird if that
makes sense
personally and then in joining my life
with another person i would hope to be
with someone who
could match you know match my level of
intensity in some way shape or form and
so
to me it's kind of being able to
accomplish something before
we even get married so that's our first
accomplishment as a couple is going into
our marriage debt free
and i grew up with you know a lot of
really supportive great family and i
want to honor the people that came
before me and leave a legacy for the
younger people behind me because when i
was
7 or when i was 27 i didn't have kids
and i wasn't married but i thought
what's the best way to prepare
if god you know blesses me in that
position and so
i thought okay well right now i can do
my best to get myself in a good
situation so that if i join with someone
else i can go
in as prepared as possible and so yeah
that's really what it came down to
and now i am you know married and have
have a bonus daughter so
it's it kind of worked out okay all
right so
justin you have a daughter from previous
alpha has a daughter alpha i'm sorry i
got that i'm sorry
our daughter okay right she's your
daughter okay is she with you
she's here okay what's her name her name
is adama oh
oh she's beautiful and how old is she
she's eight years old okay very cool
awesome
so has she been practicing a debt free
screen does she know how to do this
yeah we had her prep maybe a little bit
all right very good all right so tell us
uh what is the key
to getting out of debt each of you
sticking to the plan
staying focused staying determined uh
it's interesting because there were
times when i had
lots of money coming in big checks five
here 15 here
and i bring it home and i look at it and
then
jacent will call me and say uh okay you
got this money what are you gonna do
with it
and you know there's all kind of things
you can buy oh yeah
my tv's down uh i need to get tents on
the car
she's like just put the whole thing on
the deck
and sometimes at first that's very
difficult yeah
it's very difficult yeah it is so once i
got over that hump
that broken mentality that um
neglectful way of thinking with money it
was kind of easy after that once i put
that first
big lump sum down everything just
followed through then and i'm thinking
about my offspring i'm thinking about
the future
i'm thinking about what we want to
accomplish later as well i wanna get
married i gotta get rid of this debt
absolutely
extremely motivating it's funny because
i one day he was talking about
adding on more side hustles and i was
like what are you talking what are you
talking about and he's like
can you be quiet i'm trying to marry you
so he was
oh that's what you're doing and i
haven't even told him
that when he said he was going to pay
off his debt and gave the deadline
i it wasn't that i was skeptical and
that i didn't believe he could do it
but it was just he paid the majority of
it in like two three months
so i think that you know what you've
mentioned about focused intensity
times god is unstoppable momentum and
the things that happen when you make a
decision and commit yourself to that
are incredible like you can't even make
this stuff up
hey man you guys are powerhouse man you
guys are heroes i'm so honored to meet
you
very very well done very well done
and i like that phrase neglectful
thinking
i had to abandon that neglectful
thinking that's a real that's a powerful
phrase
it really is well done all right
adama you ready you ready you ready
all right alpha and jacent
i'm just going to total it together we
heard the story they did it separately
but now they're together
130 000 paid off in three
years his portion in eight months
making 17 to 60 for her 28 to 65 for him
from las vegas nevada count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one we are debt-free
[Applause]
fantastic very well done
man that's incredible it really is they
are
powerful my goodness it just shows you
they the power
of making decisions and the right people
around you what you can make happen
yep good stuff that is man watch out for
them they're gonna make some stuff
happen
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
i knew it from the very beginning that i
was meant to be a hair stylist and
create
the paperwork is my least favorite part
about running my business
i knew there was a better way to do my
taxes around here we're
big believers and high quality real
estate agents
that's why we found the best agents in
your area to work directly with you
these folks actually care about your
financial journey
they hate debt as much as you do and
won't sweet talk you into accepting a
deal you're not comfortable with
oh yeah and there's no extra fee to work
with them you'll get access to the
profiles of trusted agents in your area
you can expect those agents to contact
you directly in less than 24 hours
it doesn't matter if you're buying or
selling or both
we're here to help so if you're ready to
get started
let us help make this experience simple
and rewarding
with the top trusted endorsed local
providers in your area
go to daveramsey.com agents and find
your agent today
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you
every step of the way just like they've
helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's special offer
hey folks welcome back i'm here with
alpha and justin and adama who just did
their debt free scream congratulations
guys
thank you thank you so you you i heard
some of your story on the anthony o'neil
show check that out guys if you haven't
seen that yet go to anthony's youtube
channel
and watch her she was talking about how
she wasn't gonna get married until
this guy paid off debt how does it feel
now to be here doing your debt-free
scream now that that's happened
it's awesome it's amazing it's very
inspirational
we're grateful yeah yeah so you talked
also on that video about how you took on
a lot of side hustles you mentioned you
do
a lot of different things too a lot of
people find it hard to take on side
hustles i think they don't have enough
time what would you say to those people
i would say to first think about
what you do best uh because sometimes
that will help and go the long way
and you know whatever is available you
know whatever is available whatever you
can stand whatever you can manage
it's only temporary it's just a stepping
stone for you and then stick to the plan
yeah that's awesome are there any shout
outs in just a few seconds that you guys
want to give while we're here
definitely want to shout out our
families and you know my judge
my cousins and all my great friends and
all of our good friends
our families our parents everyone who
has done whatever they could to support
us
and keep us on track that's awesome
we're proud of you guys more show coming
up
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two
five david is with us in chicago
hi david welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey good afternoon dave and chris
it's an absolute pleasure absolutely how
can we help brother
hey so i work for a large manufacturing
company
with locations throughout the u.s and i
aspire to be in management
and the company culture is to every
three to five years go to a different
division
and a different position enroll and so
with that cadence
i am debt-free but i'm looking to for
some guidance
on renting versus buying um
as you're you know climbing the ladder
of a career
most of the time with a three to a five
year range you would buy
the only thing you don't want to do is
to buy in a market
uh where the i mean in a city where the
real estate market is stagnant
and so uh you know like for instance if
you're going in and you say well
i've got a four year window at this city
uh you would ask the real estate agent
for
some indicators of how hot the market is
what's the in the neighborhood that i'm
looking in what's the dom the average
days on the market how fast does a house
sell
and if you hear 28 days and you've got a
real hot market
if you hear 280 days it takes nine
months no we're not
that's a slow stagnant market uh
in that case and the other thing you
want to ask them about is about
appreciation
during that time how much is the house
going to go up in value or how much of
homes in that area in that neighborhood
gone up in value
they can pull those stats from the mls
very quickly it's not hard to do
and and so if you've got usually they
run together by the way if you've got a
a real hot market and the houses sell
quickly then usually you have
a a good high appreciation the thing's
going up enough per year
that you'll make enough on the house to
not only pay the expenses but make a
profit
and of course if you live there five
years then that's it if you ended up
changing jobs and staying then that's it
too so you're
you're owning the house the whole time
now if you're going to be there only two
years
you're going to find some markets where
you're not there enough to
house won't go up enough in value you'd
end up losing money selling it even if
it was a hot market
right yeah and david the other thing i'd
remind you to do and this is what's
gotten a lot of people into trouble
is as they buy a house and they move
because they're transferred
they try to hold on to that house and
then have it as a rental property
well again you don't want to go that
route so the thing i would tell you is
to make sure
if you are going to be there over that
two years or that three year window
just make sure you sell set house before
you move on to the next one
okay yeah that sounds good i've had that
idea before so that that clears that up
yeah yeah very good man hey thank you
for the call that's a that's some good
good question
yes sam's in baltimore maryland hey sam
welcome to the dave ramsey
show hey dave how's it going better than
i deserve how can we help
all right so uh the the short and sweet
of it is uh i have a car
i'd like to sell it uh buy something in
cash
with the the proceeds of the sale of the
vehicle because i have some positive
equity in it
and then use the money that would have
went to monthly payments for the next
three years
uh to pay down debt and to go towards
retirement
problem is my wife doesn't want me to do
that your wife doesn't want to get out
of debt
well her opinion is we're going to get
out of debt
quick enough without having to do that
and she thinks i'll be unhappy if i get
rid of my car
i kind of agree with her but
uh also i think logically and watching
your share over the last couple weeks
just got tuned in to you
um it makes more sense to get rid of the
car
how long have you been married sam
11 years okay and what other debt do you
have outside of the car
so we have uh 25 000
in credit cards we have a debt
consolidation loan
that's about 15 000. um i will say this
we have about 30 000 in inheritance
that we should be receiving in the next
month or so so that's
essentially going to knock it down to
about 10 000 left we have a really good
income
also um so we make about 235 annually
what are you online what do you owe on
the car
so uh the car i have 32
um my multi payments are about 690.
i could sell it and the value of the car
is about 50. so i'd have
just under about 20 000 to buy something
used
why do you have so much supposed vehicle
equity
did you put a lot of down on this thing
or did you get a great deal
yes not well both um
yeah put a lot down and i had quite a
bit down
okay uh so let me get this straight
after the inheritance comes in
you have a thirty two thousand dollar
car payment and you have a ten thousand
dollar debt forty two thousand and you
make two fifty
uh two thirty about two thirty five okay
my wife also has a car
that's thirty thousand that's at a zero
percent interest rate we just
got that that's we actually put quite a
bit down on that as well
um so i figured i'd throw that in the
picture too
okay so you don't have do you have any
other debt other than we've heard so far
it was like a thousand dollars she still
is for student loans
so that can be paid off pretty quick and
we have a surplus every month of
like around five thousand dollars after
taxes and gas and groceries and bills
and stuff so
that's what i'm saying we can pay these
the loans down but i'd rather
even if we didn't have any debt i'd
rather take that extra money every month
at 690
and put more towards retirement
okay um here's what i'm hearing
you're not doing a detailed written
budget and both of you are not agreeing
on it
because you're just taking broad swings
at these numbers as i'm asking you these
questions
that's number one number two uh
she and you are not on the same page on
how important it is to get out of debt
and there is no intensity it's just
something you're kind of wandering along
poking at
i i absolutely agree with the second uh
thing
the first one we do actually have a
pretty good budget
um well you suck at it because out of
235 thousand dollars you only found 60
000
freed up right now you need to tighten
that puppy up that tells me there's no
intensity
you were you were right about that for
sure yeah that's what i meant that's why
i thought you didn't have a budget
because that's not enough i mean you
should here's the thing
if you guys i think if you were if you
were intense and both of you were dialed
in
and you were willing to sacrifice i'd
say you keep both cars
pay them through you're gonna be done
really really fast it's only 70
000 bucks out of 235. you should have
that done in like
nine months or eight months and then
yeah i wouldn't move down
out of that car making that kind of
money i'd stay right there in that car
and you like the car you did say that
so um i would agree with her then i do
not agree
with her not being intense on getting
out of debt
and thinking you're gonna wander your
butt out of it in the next three years
making a quarter of a million dollars a
year so her suggestion with her lack of
intensity don't go together
so you need to decide which one you're
going to be if you want to be intense
and focused and be done with it in seven
or eight months
keep them both and pay them off and both
of you roll up your sleeves and get on
beans and rice and get this mess cleaned
up
and then you've got more than 7.90 you
got her car payment your car payment
no payments all of that to invest and
you move right on up into baby steps
you will free it up and that's really
what you ought to do yeah but if you're
gonna
wander around in this crap for three or
four years
and just be you know half butt doing it
then
you know yeah sell a car sell at all
shop her car too yeah
but i think you know sam you sitting
down and talking with her and finding
out what's the hesitation
what's the thing that's going on and
really get connected like you guys
you've got too much of an income
coming in to be wandering around in this
situation and here's the problem
if you don't put some guidelines in
place you guys will add a boat
a motorcycle and a bigger home in a
matter of years
and you look up and you will really be
wondering what happened so it's time to
wake up buddy
you guys get connected this should turn
up the heat you guys going to get on the
same page on that part of it
and because the problem is you're
running out down two different tracks
and so you're coming to two different
conclusions
and and that you know that's what's
happening so there's there's not a right
or a wrong answer
in in this moment the right answer is
when we get on the same track that's
going to give you the you're going to
have a parallel conclusion then
and uh you'll both be going yeah sell
the car or don't sell the car i don't
think you need to sell it i think you
need to get
both of you get intense both of you get
sacrificial and just get the dadgum mess
cleaned up that's what i would do if i
were in your shoes
hey man we appreciate you listening
thanks for calling in
chris hogan good hour thank you sir it
was fun james childs our producer kelly
daniel our social producer and phone
screener i'm dave ramsey your host
and we'll be back
[Music]
so
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
it's very simple i like to spend my time
outdoors when it comes time to do my
taxes i'd like to have a professional
who's got integrity take care of that lo
and behold i found somebody i like
terry's situation was a little unique in
that he had some more complex tax issues
that he had to deal with and so we were
able to get a good overview of what was
going on and then put a game plan
together of how we could get it resolved
for him
he gave me a lot of confidence that they
knew what they were talking about what
they were doing and he's been my tax guy
ever since
[Music]
we're all going to retire at some point
or another
and you're probably asking yourself
what's this thing social security
well if you're asking yourself that
question you're not the only one
i'm about to break it down
[Music]
social security was created in 1935 it
was a way to help supplement income
so american workers have social security
taxes taking out of their income
now this money isn't taken out of your
check and put aside just for you
a lot of people think it's my own
personal account no not at all
actually the social security
administration will take that money from
your check
and put it in a pool to be able to
supplement and give out to the
beneficiaries
beneficiaries means these are people
that are actively withdrawing or taking
on social security
right now you can claim social security
benefits
as early as age 62 or as late as age 70.
but right now to be considered fully
retired the age is 67.
now i want to encourage you with this
the earlier that you start to
take money out the less that you'll get
the longer that you wait
the more that you'll get so it's really
important to understand that nuance
and make sure you're making a wise
decision now you've probably received
some type of statement in from the
social security administration
showing you how much you're due right
now remember that's an approximation
that's not a guarantee so what you want
to do is grab that little statement
and make sure you're connecting with
your investment professional to really
talk through
and understand what that might actually
look like as you get closer to
retirement age
according to the social security
administration the average payout right
now in social security is around
thirteen hundred and sixty nine dollars
a month
now that's 38 less than the national
poverty level
for a two-person family in retire
inspired i talk about social security
and really walk through the details the
most important thing is
don't count on it like if it's there
then that's great but if it's not
i want you to have money that you've set
aside to be able to live your dreams
so now the big question with social
security i get asked this all the time
is social security going to be around
for you so as it stands right now
social security is fully funded until
the year 2034.
after that there's only enough money in
there for about 77
of the scheduled benefits but get this
the number of people that are going to
be 65 and up
is also going to increase so the amount
of money available is going down and the
number of people needing it is going to
go
up you can see the issue there so the
bottom line is
you want to make sure that you have a
plan for you and your family
i don't want you to count on social
security if it's there
great but i want you to make sure that
you're utilizing your 401ks
your roth iras iras all the things that
you have available to you
to make sure you're building your nest
egg you've worked too hard and for too
long
but there's still time i don't care how
old you are or where you stand right now
you've got an opportunity to be able to
help yourself
so the goal is get proactive increase
your knowledge
make sure you understand and believe
that you still have time that you can do
this
and most importantly start the right
kinds of habits
budgeting getting yourself out of debt
and starting to invest
you may not be where you want to be but
i want you to get focused
get started today let's not waste
another moment to impact your financial
future
right now 78 percent of americans are
living paycheck
to paycheck that means if you look
around your own neighborhood
eight out of ten families on your street
cannot cover a basic emergency
they might not be able to afford their
mortgage payment
they're not keeping their own money
they're sending a
fourth of their paycheck to car payments
student loans and the credit card
companies
and the worst part most of these folks
don't even know why they're stressed
while they're fighting with their spouse
while there's too much month
left at the end of the money it's not
okay
they shouldn't have to live that way
what if you could help them win with
money
you can as a financial peace university
coordinator
our coordinators have helped over 5
million people
learn how to pay off debt spend and save
wisely and ultimately
change their lives if you have a heart
for helping people
then you're the perfect person to become
a coordinator
and you don't need a lot of time or any
special training plus someone from my
team will walk alongside you and
guide you through the entire process
join
us in changing lives and take the first
step
to becoming a financial peace university
coordinator
[Music]
today
what do we sell around here hope
you're in shipping is what you ship if
you're developing it's what you develop
we do exist for those that are not here
we're here because we were a group of
people
banded together that care care deeply
every day marriages are impacted
people's family trees are changed count
it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
[Applause]
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
i'm wanting to come clean out a credit
card that he doesn't know about i'm
gonna probably pay
student loans for the rest of my life i
just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey show
you are not a victim you are the hero in
your story
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career everything just
started making sense
i was like i'm gonna do this let's hear
a debt-free scream
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the
dave ramsey show where debt is dumb cash
is king and the paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice chris hogan ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five raiden is in new york hi raiden how
are you
good thank you so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
all righty so i have ten thousand
dollars in student loan debt
going into my junior year of college i
found your show
four months ago and i'm halfway through
chris's book right now i'm trying to
get out of debt and change my future
since i found you guys
so i started a plumbing business two
months ago and i'm
making more money than i ever have in my
life so my question is
should i take a year or a semester off
of college and focus on crushing out my
current debt
or should i go into my next year of
college paying out of pocket
and then slowly chipping away at my
existing debt as i go
b
okay easy enough
uh let me let me think through this okay
how much money are you making
you said you're making more money than
you've ever made in your life yeah so my
first year i brought in
my first month two months ago i made
three thousand last month
i made around five thousand and this
month i'm projected to make even more
good for you where'd it go man
i'm proud of you yes thank you
so i mean chris do you see i mean i i
think you can get through get through
college and then you'll be able to knock
if you haven't knocked the 10 out by the
time you get through cash flow college
is job one yep
the job twos knock off the tent as fast
as you can
but um dude what are you studying in
school
called the supply chain management ah
very good
yeah very good yeah that degree is gonna
afford you
a great income even better than you're
making now and
um i should anyway and uh uh
most of the undergrads are coming out in
the 80 000 range that i've seen
lately uh doing that and yeah i mean
that's that's pretty strong
yeah i i like this rate and i like that
plan plan b
uh because it will you're going to be
able to knock out that student loan debt
at the rate you're going
you know but as they were saying job one
is the cash flow and make sure you're
able to take care of this
of school and then everything else is
going toward that debt you're going to
have that thing gone here in
another matter of months way to go yeah
you got to feel like you got to feel
like you got this thing by the tail man
good job
thank you so much guys i really
appreciate the wisdom thank you so much
you're very welcome
avoid the 80 000 truck that you'll start
to rationalize in your mind to carry
your plumbing equipment
right so just don't don't don't go that
route
right like keep thinking differently and
remain aware raiden
there's a system out there to try to get
as much money from you as possible
and as soon as you let your guard down
that's when it creeps up so
keep your guard up stay aware my friend
and keep working the plan
soraya is with us in new york hi soraya
how are you
good thanks dave for taking my call
thanks to you and chris
i am calling because um part of my
compensation
uh package that my company gives me they
give me restricted stock which i can't
touch for three years
and now some of that unrestricted stock
has become unrestricted and i'm just
wondering what
i should do or could do with it well you
can sell it
if you want to uh what what stage of the
baby steps are you in how are you doing
i am on baby step two and i will be
completely debt-free next month with the
exception of my house
great and how much unrestricted stock
value do you have if you sold all your
unrestricted stock
a little bit over four thousand oh i'd
sell it yeah for sure
okay put it in your emergency fund
finish up your debt and then start your
baby step three right
yep yeah i mean it's just sitting there
and you can get you turned into money it
was
it was compensation is what it was right
yes
yeah and so you worked x number of time
it became unrestricted which then gives
you access to it
you have every right that has nothing to
say about what you feel about your
employer
by you selling it or any of this stuff
uh this is money that's sitting there
and available for you
so use it to your advantage young lady
good call good question so the beginning
of the year
um house prices i don't know what
they're going to do
in this upcoming year it's going to be
absolutely crazy if your plans got
sidetracked last year and you're
thinking about home ownership or maybe
you're thinking about selling and you
got sidetracked by the old
pandemic wolf he's out there huffing and
puffing
you might want to start as you're
remaking your decision whether to kick
back in at the first
year or not you might want to start with
a good solid real estate agent
and not everyone that has real estate
license knows what they're doing as a
matter of fact
most of them don't most of them don't
about 80 percent of them are doughnut
eaters they sit in the office and eat
donuts
and that they don't you know seriously
it is truly a pareto principle
eighty percent of them make twenty
percent of the sales twenty percent of
them make eighty percent of the things
and of the twenty percent that make
eighty percent of the sales 20
of those make 80 of those sales wow i
mean it it really is it
you know the the cream does come to the
top pretty quick here
we have researched and worked with only
high quality high
octane high protein real estate agents
for many years
and we've allowed them to become
endorsed local providers
people that we endorse for your next
home purchase
or your next home sale and these are the
best of the best
high octane high volume they know what
they're doing they're
actually selling houses they didn't just
get their license and wish they did
they actually do it so text the word
house
to 33 789 house
two three three seven eight
nine and chris i think that because
not because of the pandemic but because
of the shutdowns
associated with the pandemic and the
draconian
rules in some of these states we're
seeing people
leave california and new york by the
droves we really are
and it's going to create it's creating a
high demand market in some
other areas so real estate's heating up
in some other areas and eventually
you're going to have a cool down in some
of those other in some of these areas
where they're leaving
we haven't seen it yet right we have not
seen california house prices drop yet
uh-uh we've not seen new york house
prices drop yet
but we will yes if you keep stopping the
supply demand curve you still
keep screwing around with it there's
going to be a lot more supply than there
is demand
either way whether you're navigating a
potentially slowing market
or a market that's heating up you need a
pro yeah you got it's too much at risk
and too much
at stake i was talking to a friend out
of new york and he said you know the
the rents are starting to even come down
uh
and the upscale living apartments and
condos and all that are
becoming more and more empty people are
leaving so first thing that comes is the
rents and then the values will come down
after that yeah
so you know this is something you've
worked too hard uh you don't want to
leave it to chance
you want to deal with someone that knows
that market inside and out and can
properly guide you
whether you're selling or relocating and
so
you're going to be in phenomenal hands
talking with one of our real estate elps
and you know i had a guy call on the air
yesterday
uh when john deloney and i were on
together and said um
that his wife's uncle was selling the
house they were living in in phoenix
because he thinks since biden got
elected that the economy is going to
crash right after the first of the year
and in phoenix arizona and i'm like
listen dude
you have post election stress disorder
yeah you you have a mental illness here
you need to take a nap
yeah that's not relevant it will val and
besides that you know
maybe in some areas but is the entire
economy going to crash in january
no come on
[Applause]
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys george campbell here and i am
out of the office and downtown and
here's why
when we're at the ramsey office it's
easy to be in a bubble and be around
people who think
just like i do when it comes to money so
i thought let's get around some normal
people
and see what they think when it comes to
finances we are taking it to the street
let's do it if you had no payments in
the world no mortgage no student loan
debt what would you do
[Music]
what would i do i would be debt free how
would that feel
it'd be awesome if you had no payments
in the world no student loans no rent
nothing how would your life be different
how would it feel
it would feel great i would travel the
world i would buy a house
i would probably like work part-time
and not even have to stress out about
anything at all
what would you do with no debt no debt
go on trips
more trust live life yes how about you
what would you do with no debt
um a charity like a yeah
help kids who are like in some more like
dead situations
like give more be more generous yeah oh
god yeah i think yeah if i didn't have
to have that kind of little
demon in the back of my mind reminding
me that i've got these payments to make
i'd feel a lot more relaxed um i think
we like to travel it's kind of our main
thing
so if if i didn't have have those loans
you'd probably travel a bit more
if you didn't have a payment in the
world how would it feel and what would
you do
[Music]
feel awesome and i would travel more
i'd buy more plane tickets that's what i
would do travel
yeah we would definitely travel i don't
travel more no more experiences
yeah definitely travel get out of the
country travel probably travel
i would like to travel some more i like
to travel so if you had no payments in
the world no car payment no student
loans no
nothing what would you do with your life
differently i'd probably live somewhere
else
and i'd have a nicer car well yeah what
car do you have now
i have a jeep compass that's a great car
i think her vehicle is fine
with what she had i had a feeling mom
was gonna say that your car is fine
step one one thousand dollars to start
your emergency fund
step two pay off all debt using the debt
snowball
step three three to six months of
expenses in
savings step four invest fifteen percent
of household income
in roth iras and pre-tax retirement
step five college funding for children
step six pay off house early
step seven build wealth and give
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you
every step of the way just like they've
helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's special offer
[Music]
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal
so today's question comes from angela in
wisconsin she says my job was recently
eliminated
i was vested in the company pension plan
i received a mailing from the pension
group
with info about my benefits my options
are
seven hundred dollars a month starting
at age 65
or a 25 000 lump sum payout now
i have been told i wouldn't be able to
grow 25 000 into what i would need to
make 700 monthly
at retirement so i should leave the
pension alone
wondering your thoughts on this well
angela here's the deal first and
foremost i don't have your age
on here so i don't know but it seems
like someone's making a reach and
assuming and you know what happens when
you assume
that you couldn't grow this 25 000 in a
lump to become
much more than what it is so i'm a fan
of the lump sum payment i think it'll
give you an opportunity to grow
because you're going to have better
investing options than just what's
inside that pension
yeah you take it and you roll it over in
a direct transfer roll over into an ira
place it in good growth stock mutual
funds that have a 10-year track record
or more
we suggest and i personally do this
chris personally does this spreading it
across four types
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international
if you need someone to help you do that
sit down with one of the smart vester
pros by clicking smart fester
at daveramsey.com now whoever is telling
you this chris is exactly right their
math is wrong here's how i know their
math is wrong even though i don't know
their age
pensions are highly regulated they are
not allowed to invest
aggressively at all and so a pension
rate of return
is always set at around six or seven
percent
your 25 000 will grow to enough at six
or seven percent to create seven hundred
dollars
if it stays in the pension we know that
otherwise they wouldn't give you these
numbers that's true okay and if it will
grow
to enough to create seven hundred
dollars at six or seven percent the
regulated
amount that you're going to find in
almost every pension
then we are very sure that if it does
better than six percent
seven percent you're going to have more
than 700 dollars and so
i think whoever told you this is um
making some different assumptions or
possibly just doesn't know what the crap
they're talking about
edna is with us in virginia beach hi
edna how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i'm a new listener brand new to the baby
steps
um so i'm kind of jumping ahead here
thinking about
step two and um just from listening i
know that
consolidation company programs are a
no-go
um i unfortunately went through one of
those um i'm done with it
however when it comes to the debt that i
already have
should i go back and add those
uh consolidations that i've settled with
the other banks
they're settled they're done okay so the
consolidation company played all the way
through and
every loan that was in that program is
now settled is that what you're telling
me
that's correct yeah okay yeah yeah you
just leave that alone that's over
that's in your past it was settled it's
just they're done they're settled you
don't know you don't have a debt anymore
yeah i have
so you just have a traditional baby step
two left then which is just
your debt snowball credit yeah yeah and
then just stay focused so how much do
you have left young lady
for my current debt yes ma'am uh
16 500 and most of it is my car okay
yeah good good yeah so that's where you
stay focused on right now and
and just remember when you're trying to
get out of debt don't add any
right like don't go looking at another
car uh
don't do anything that's going to move
you backwards and and i say that
tongue-in-cheek but i'm being very
serious uh because you can so easily
catch yourself getting into
a deserved mentality especially as we
get ready to come into these holidays
if you've been making some sacrifices
and cutting back you'll start to feel
like that hey
woe is me and no no no no you just want
to stay clear and stay focused on what
you're chasing down
you know you brought that up a couple
times today and it bears repeating
mathematically speaking the hardest
and the most important step to getting
out of debt
is to simply stop borrowing
because if you stop borrowing and you
pay your payments
eventually even if you don't pay extra
eventually
you'll be debt free that's right now you
aren't you're not gazelle intense you're
not making super progress it's not super
fun
but i mean if you just pay your house
payment eventually pays off
if you pay your car payment eventually
it pays off even your stupid credit card
if you just pay the payment it has some
principle in there eventually 42 years
from now
it will pay off so if you just pay your
payments yeah
and stop borrowing that is that
you just tilted the you just tilted the
table in your direction you sure did
and then from there you start piling up
piling some more wood on the fire
and you start attacking that debt using
the debt snowball and picking up extra
jobs and selling as much stuff the kids
think they're next
then you can really get the things
moving you know this
the problem is you're right the holidays
come around
christmas is here and it snuck up on
somebody yep
oh god it's in december this year yeah
who knew and and you know
and and you drive by the car lot and
there's that little reflection
off of that shine catches your eye
you're telling me my head or the car no
the car
okay i wasn't looking at your head let's
check it it's just the shine off that
car
catches your eye that gleam it is kinda
like your head though
and uh now that you're mentioning i
don't know anybody like that but
but it does and in that day you know
something something shiny
and you know what it is is i get this
way i'm this way with a chocolate donut
i deserve it i've worked really hard
today
are melissa's over there in the dead gum
ramsey kitchen cooking those homemade
chocolate chip cookies
they're of the devil yes and uh she's
not but they are
and you smell that smell when i come out
of the studio
and i deserve one of those cookies yeah
yeah you know
and we do this with everything you know
but you know what that is that's a
little kid inside of every one of us
and it's still there because children do
what feels good yeah
adults devise a plan and follow it yeah
and you're exactly right you can just
fall back
into an entitled mentality well
you know i didn't think about christmas
it snuck up on me i
you know i didn't think that car was
gonna jump out there well and think
about it this year
if you're not able to see family because
you haven't seen them as much
you're thinking i'm going to make this
the best christmas ever
and then what happens you overextend
yourself a little emotion goes
got the emotion or you've got some guilt
or shame because you haven't been able
to see them i want people to just reset
take a clear breath and this is a year
to make christmas be a little bit
different
you know let's be smart and let's be
more more focused on the budget
more than ever and give yourself a leg
up to start 2021
on the good foot not the debt foot hey
you know what let's give him some money
we're the ramsey christmas giveaway
we're giving away 500
a week that's true that's not bad you
can go to daveramsey.com
giveaway no purchase necessary you can
register every day
and we're going to give away 500 a week
and we're going to win we're going to
give away a grand prize of 5 000
wow as well dave ramsey.com giveaway
and uh while you're there if you want to
see that shine you can see chris's head
on his book and it's the everyday
millionaires number one best-selling
book it's right there
for ten dollars yup and there's a shine
right there i see it right there on the
cover
that coming off those gleaming white
teeth and uh
photoshop is wonderful
and uh all our books are on sale for ten
dollars at daveramsey.com
so you can go over there and check all
that stuff out and the total money
makeover
uh just got word the other day we sold
our eighth eight millionth copy
wow and so uh pretty crazy you can get
it for 10 bucks
any of chris's number one selling books
or any of rachel's
any of uh delony's new quick read is ten
dollars
redefining anxiety came out this week
and
uh uh of course rachel's two best
sellers uh coleman's best seller
anthony's best sellers they're all
businesses they're all ten dollars
and while you're there be sure you
register for the
five hundred dollar giveaway you can
register once a day
daveramsey.com giveaway
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay when you get married you become one
in
every aspect of your life okay one in
every aspect including your money
now some people don't like this idea in
fact
i put up an instagram little box one
time and it said
combine your accounts or something along
those lines that's something i say all
the time
it's amazing to me that i'm like take
down the credit card companies in
america and people like sure and then
i'm like combine your accounts if you're
married and like what
you just like ran over my dog who are
you the worst person in the world
i mean the hate that came out of nowhere
i was like
tears lord people calm down number one
but number two
yes i'm sorry i'm sorry sometimes i'm
like you can do your thing i'll do mine
but this is proven you guys people that
work together with their money they
combine it they see it not as she or
he but we together they win faster when
it comes to money
and the comment that bothered me
probably the most is people that said
well we
thought so much about money and then we
separated it all and now we have a great
marriage
i'm sorry you separated it to avoid
a topic that's hard in marriage oh
avoidance
i'm not a marriage counselor but i do
not think it's probably a good factor
here okay
so that means yes when you combine your
accounts you might have conflict you
guys
but conflict is key conflict is a
good thing when it's done in the right
way
conflict gets below the surface it means
that you get to
have your independent thought which may
be different than your spouse's and
that's okay
talk about it because the deal is when
you work through stuff
you get to know your spouse on a
different level you you have a level of
intimacy that's not that's not there if
you just say oh everything's fine we're
gonna just kind of avoid hard subjects
and just live life okay
so getting down in the muck and uh the
not fun part of stuff and you have
conflict yeah it's hard it's not easy
but the team that's connected there like
what happens
after that conflict and you come
together and you say you know what we
are
we are a more tight-knit unit it's
amazing it's amazing
what happens in your marriage when you
do that when you fight you actually grow
closer and when i say fight i'm saying
it in a healthy way okay not like the
bad stuff but like
truly having good healthy conflict less
parrot says conflict is the price we pay
for a deeper level of intimacy and i
love that okay so
it's okay to go into this disagreeing
with your spouse but this is gonna
force you guys to talk about stuff to
talk about
money and the great thing about money is
money is just like
it's the thing you're talking about but
what it expounds upon
is really your goals in life your fears
your dreams so much more is there okay
so get vulnerable to your spouse talk
about the hard stuff because i promise
you will have a deeper more intimate
marriage when you do
if you've read anything i've ever
written you've never heard me recommend
more than a 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage now why not do a 30-year
mortgage
why not well dave i could take out a
30-year mortgage in case there's a
problem
then i could reduce to the lesser amount
but i pay it like it's a 15
and pay it off in 15. what's wrong with
that what's wrong with this
that is prom dresses transmissions
vacations
christmas life happens and you never do
oh well i will
no you won't the fdic says that 97.3
percent
of mortgages are not systematically
prepaid
they're prepaid some of them but not
systematically meaning you
pay your 30 like a 15 that means 2.7
percent of people actually do it
don't put yourself in a position you
have to be in the top 2.7 to win
put yourself in a position where you're
going to win and that's a 15-year fixed
rate
we've done detailed research 100 percent
of 15-year fixed-rate mortgages
pay off in 15 years hello so
you don't take out more than a 15-year
mortgage
ever and it's not this much more
expensive you would think if it went
from a 30 to a 15
that if you cut the term in half that it
would double the payment
it doesn't double the payment it's just
a little bit more compared to the amount
of dollars you're going to save by not
having a mortgage
for 15 whole years listen get yourself
out of debt
get the house paid off as fast as you
can and don't figure out how long you
can stay in debt
figure out how quick you can get out of
debt it's the wrong question to say
dave is there a way i can cheat this and
not pay extra on my
mortgage and therefore get out of debt
no pay extra
pay treaty like it's a seven year treat
like it's a five year
treat your mortgage like it's a car loan
get it knocked out get rid of it because
when you don't have any payments baby
you know what you got options you got
options to give
you got options to live like nobody else
never do a 30-year mortgage only do a
15.
the savings is dramatic and you're
tricking yourself into getting out of
debt
at least in 15 years people call my show
all the time complaining about how
awful their time shares are and yet you
guys have been
really having good success getting
people out of their timeshares
we have we kind of helped create this
industry now there's
a lot of exit companies out there they
come and they go timeshare extra team is
different
i mean we we now have you know almost 20
000 people out of timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
our guarantee is that if we can't get
you out of your timeshare we give you
your money back
hey if you need out timeshare exit team
is the team the only team
that i trust to help you schedule your
free consultation
by calling 844 999
exit or timeshareexitteam.com
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host here on the show today open
phones at
825-5225 matt is with us in phoenix
hey matt how are you great how are you
doing today
better than i deserve what's up so
i um have been following the baby steps
for a few years now me and my wife
probably about five and i'm actually a
big advocate i love what you preach and
um i probably got a half dozen over the
years about a half dozen clients that
i've kind of
deferred you guys away so i never really
thought i'd find myself
in this situation uh basically my wife
and i thought we were
going to pay off our house and that's
kind of where we're at we don't have any
debt all our cars are
free and clear and we don't carry credit
card debt and
we had this opportunity come up this
year
very niche real estate opportunity where
basically we got to use buy and hold
rental properties
and um we were using
our uh our primary house we did i'm sure
you're familiar with the product
all in one mortgage it's basically a
line of credit that's
taxes the first mortgage with the
checking component built into it
and so anyways we we bought four
investment properties this year
uh on a whim because they cash flowed
really well
we did 15 down loans uh no mi
uh or pmi and um and
uh basically the mortgage payments are
between eight hundred to a thousand
dollars a piece
and they cash flow about four thousand
dollars a month well
their gross is four thousand so they
cash flow about three grand and we
bought four of these and
obviously it's been great for us um it's
really kind of accelerated our debt
payoff
instead of looking to have our primary
house paid off
in 2022 we're probably going to get paid
off sometime
next year in 2021 um the thing that
we're running into
is as we did this because we've always
kind of followed the
you know not leveraging uh uh approach
um but i think my wife and i have both
kind of gotten nervous that we've pulled
out
um yeah about six hundred thousand
dollars in mortgage debt between the
four houses
even though they're cash flowing really
well um and the opportunity
basically none of these houses have any
vacancy um
and we're getting pressured to get even
more because we literally have a waiting
list of tenants that want to move in
because of the kind of niche opportunity
it is
so my question to you is if we can still
get our primary house paid off
uh next year and um continue to grow
into these other
you know buy and hold properties do you
think this is a a
bad like do you think we're is this a
formula for misfortune that we keep
you know snagging some of these with the
cash flow being as good as they are
i'm a little confused do you think we're
all concerned stop stop stop
stop i'm a little confused okay i
thought you started this call with how
you had listened to us and followed us
for years
yeah yeah okay then you know then you
know the answer to the question
if you've listened to me and followed me
for years you've never heard me tell
people to do what you're doing
yeah it's true okay that's true and i
certainly wouldn't tell you to do more
of what you're doing
right yeah you followed the plan you
followed the plan until you stopped
following the plan
exactly exactly and so
so that that's just kind of like it's
it's basically come into another source
of income for us and right listen i
don't know
listen listen go ahead i have a source
of income too
several hundred million dollars have
paid for real estate
that never had a mortgage on it once and
i did not use leverage to build it i
used cash to build it
matt you're gonna get in trouble because
you have not
factored risk into this scenario
and leverage is a two-edged sword it
cuts
both ways
here are the phrases you have just
continued to say things all through this
conversation that indicates you have
no measure of risk whatsoever in this
okay dave
you own more real estate than anybody
else i know
i want you to hear these phrases niche
real estate
niche yeah yeah okay hold on bought four
properties on a whim
and was being pressured to buy more
what what what are we what are we doing
here
it sounds like late night real estate
get rich quick scheme
103. it's a bad plan
and it's got headache and heartache
written all over it down the road here
in just a few years my friend and the
other thing is
after talking to you for four minutes or
listening to you talk for four minutes
nothing where you say is going to change
it nope suzy's in fort wayne indiana hi
susie how are you
susie good how are you great how can we
help
good um i have a question so my husband
and i are
looking at possibly selling our home and
the reason that we want to sell it is
because it's a really big payment it
takes about 42
of our income and even once we're
debt-free it's just
that percentage keeps me up at night and
i know you guys pound into everybody's
head you know 15-year mortgage 25
of your income and i just we're getting
pressured by our family to stay in this
house
are they paying the payments no they're
not when they don't get a vote tell them
to hush
yeah get muslim i wanted to know if that
was why because i'm looking at rentals
that are about eight hundred dollars a
month versus our 1800
month mortgage payment and it just it
seems like a good idea for me but i just
wanted to know if that was like a dave
approved idea because i'm really trying
to do things the right way
is your income going to go up enough
soon enough that you're not going to be
strangled by the house no honestly i
i don't see that happening and that's
what scared and your relatives are
well-meaning but they have no idea about
your personal life and it's none of
their business
yeah yeah that's what we're doing is
your husband on board with this susie
he is it this keeps us up at night like
we
yeah you two are the only ones who have
a vote yeah
i don't even have a vote because i'm not
paying the payment now what would i do
if i woke up in your shoes
listen the whole thing is it's keeping
you up at night the reason it's keeping
you up at night
is it's taking a big chunk of your life
to just
just to own this house and you've
determined
it's not worth it now should you maybe
buy
another house instead of rent maybe and
that's what we don't qualify
that are we're just not in a position to
be able to buy because that was our
initial plan
and that is not going to work out why
don't you qualify
because um we my husband lost his job
last year when i was pregnant i was nine
months pregnant and he came home and
told me he lost his job and that's
actually how we
came to financial peace because we were
like we can't do this anymore we're not
living like this anymore and
so at his other job did he make enough
that this wasn't 42
um he did he took about an 800 to a
thousand dollar pay cut
why because he wasn't able to find
something that
what did he do before um he was a
machine operator so he he's done
different like csv type machining jobs
get his income back up to that then um
he could he actually right now he stays
home monday through thursday with our
kids
and so it's saving us a lot on child
care um
who's working to pay child care okay we
both are he works friday through sunday
and i work monday through friday but
we're both working
and so back when he had this primary
machining job you were at home
um actually he worked in the evening so
um our
yeah he watched the kids during the day
and he would go to work at night so we
didn't see each other much but we were
making
we're making really good money at that
time yeah okay if he
if he can get his income back up that
changes the answer
i asked you that earlier if he can't get
his income back
up then you may want to make the move
yeah
that's what this comes down to looking
at taking a second job
he's open to that i don't want to work a
second job
in order to keep a house that that means
you're going to be doing it for the rest
of your life
i don't want to do that that's not what
i'm talking about i'm saying he took a
step down on income because he needed
work yeah but now if he can take that
step back up in income that's right
then he's qualified and is should be
making that other income
then at his old job
then the idea yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's a good point i haven't quite
if you want to do that and you want to
keep the house
that changes the equation and so but
um relatives are well-meaning but they
don't get a vote unless they're paying
the payments and if they're paying the
payments there's other problems
that's so true dave this is the dave
ramsey show
[Music]
we started five daughters bakery solely
on
the idea of being together my husband
and i
really love to work together we enjoy
being around each other
and we loved being with our family so we
have five daughters who are growing and
time is fleeting
and we wanted to spend more time as a
family we were in a season of life where
we knew we were on the brink of
breakthrough and change
and we just knew that we needed to do
something different and very
counter-cultural
than the nine-to-five job when we got
started
we absolutely felt fearful definitely
unqualified
neither my husband or i have any
experience
in the restaurant industry we were just
baking in our kitchen
praying over little donuts in a tiny
fryer and when we first came in
honest coffee roasters they took us on
and we built momentum with them
selling out every day and people really
started to get word of our business in
the community
and so we got really excited we started
to go ask other people
do you want our donuts and we got a lot
of closed doors in our face
and so it was like well god we thought
we were stepping out we thought we had
this momentum we thought we were moving
you know those setbacks kind of made us
question in doubt did we do the right
thing
is this what we're supposed to do with
those challenges we learned
that for our story and for our journey
we were to stop and wait for open doors
we weren't to push things
open but we were to rest and hear his
voice
and look for green lights and move upon
that step by step
when things get hard my motivation to
keep going
is to look at the faces of the people
who've poured their hearts and souls out
into our bakery and have taken ownership
over that the motivation
to not give up is when i look at my
children and i
i need to show them what it looks like
to become an overcomer to persevere
to keep going it's just been a blessing
for our family to actually integrate
and work together we get to build a team
together we get to envision what it's
going to look like moving forward and we
get to
be wild because it's our life and we get
to write that story together with god
when our kids see us walking out our
dreams it's really empowering to me as a
mom
for them to see us being leaders in the
community for them to see us wearing
different hats
solving conflicts relating with other
people
that's important to us because it's
building trust and sowing truth into
their hearts about
us chasing our dreams just want to speak
to the moms out there
running a business is a lot of work but
it's very rewarding
and what you actually care about and
dream about and desire
is important so don't give up you're
important to this world
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris hogan ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five alicia
is with us in indianapolis hi alicia how
are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so i know consolidated loans are
just piling stupid on top of stupid i
totally get that i understand that
but i need you to hear me out because my
keys hurts
because what what hurts my kid hurts
your tooth i have some yes i have some
dental problems that my insurance will
not cover and there is this company
who was talking about consolidating the
remaining of our 25 000
credit card debt and they would throw in
an extra 10 000 and it would instead of
being 600 that were paying minimum
payments for credit card
it would be 140 something my question is
if i go ahead and do this which i can
then use the 10 000 to fix my teeth
and then instead of paying the 140
they're offering i continue
paying the 600 and something actually
continue paying what i'm paying which is
closer to 800.
would that make sense i know
consolidated ones are stupid but it
wouldn't extend my
debt any further because i'm paying it
faster than they expect me to
depending depending on the interest rate
it did extend your debt by ten thousand
dollars further
you need ten thousand dollars worth of
dental work i'll pull that tooth it's
like
i'm sorry it takes how long how much
it's 7 500
to fix every tooth in my mouth and this
one particular one hurts
and the dentist won't touch it because
my insurance won't cover it
i mean i'm sorry one hertz
but 7 500 to fix all of them
oh yeah i i have some sort of a calcium
thing my teeth don't get the calcium
they're supposed to get so they're um
i'm sorry let me stop a second i'm just
trying to understand all right i'm not
i'm really not trying to be smart
you have one tooth that's hurting why do
you not remove
that tooth well the dentist doesn't want
to remove that tooth until he can put
some sort of a device in for a bridge
and he won't put the device in for a
bridge until he's done some
deep cleaning or until he's capped these
other two teeth and he won't catch us
with two teeth until he does some sort
of
cleaning thing where they have to put
you out or something and it's like worse
than a regular
cleaning you need to go to a new dentist
yes
today you need to go to a new dentist
you need to get some other opinions on
this i'm not a dental
expert okay but um
here's the problem all right you have a
roof leak
and you just call me to buy a whole roof
and finance it instead of just fixing
the leak and i don't know how to do that
in your situation
again i'm not a dental expert if i were
in your shoes i would get at least
two other dentists to look at this
situation
and tell them i'm on a limited budget i
need a temporary
fix until i can save up the money for
the permanent fix
okay i believe in dental work okay and
if it is truly a 7 500
thing to be done uh we'll save up the
money and we'll get there
and i believe in avoiding pain i am i
mean i'm a complete
wuss when it comes to pain and so i'm
with you on this i'm going to pay almost
anything to not hurt
because i'm a complete wuss so i'm with
you on all of this
however um this just sounds weird yeah
it does
and it sounds like too alicia that the
debt consolidation company because you
shared this information with them
and they found showed you a way that
emotionally
they can quote unquote try to look like
they're helping you
here's the reality debt consolidation it
is a con
i mean the way that they're able to
lower your your payment is they
extend the length of time that you're in
debt that's the only way there's that
mathematical wizardry there's there's no
what she's saying if she pays the whole
the same 600 it would be out and if the
interest rate is the same
other than the 10 000 you'd be out at
exactly the same time
if you keep the same payment the same
interest rate right but that doesn't
work because you're adding ten thousand
dollars to the balance
okay i'm not going to tell you to borrow
the money okay
i'm going to tell you you when any time
i'm making a decision
and the only options are the only
options in the decision
suck it means i need more options
you have one option with your dentist
that sucks
yeah you have a tooth that hurts and not
doing something
sucks as an idea and you have this
ridiculous idea to borrow ten thousand
dollars more
by the way you only need seventy five
hundred what are we doing with the other
twenty five hundred going to cabo
um so you know uh there's just
i i think you're hurting and i get that
but i'm gonna go get two
other dentists independently look at
this and
um most people in dental practices do a
great job i endorse dentists
in many cities around america on the
local radio stations that we're on and i
do so proudly
uh i also have had a few experiences
with them
uh where they're trying to sell me a
bentley and i needed a volkswagen
yeah i actually did have this happen
when i was broke
i had a toothache the year we filed
bankruptcy
and i went to the dentist because i was
hurting because i'm a wuss i didn't have
any money i mean i
didn't know what i was going to do but i
went in there and the guy said i need to
do this is 1988.
i need to do 3 dollars worth of work to
your teeth or you're going to lose
all of your teeth within five years
i said well i'm gonna lose all of my
teeth within five years
because i don't have three thousand five
hundred dollars i can't borrow it i'm
just coming out of bankruptcy and um
so i left you know how much of that work
i've had done
how much none seriously 30 years later
every tooth is still in my head so the
guy was a complete
jacked up con wow now i'm not saying
hers is and i'm not saying other things
are right that did happen to me and so
i'm always listen any time you're
dealing with a
professional situation like this an
attorney
a tax person a investment person
a a medical professional you always
get second opinions until you find
options
that fix you that come out of a
treatment plan that fits your life and
your finances
and that's what you do because they're
counting on
sometimes your emotions and your pain
absolutely just signing any just give it
to me i'll sign it whatever it is just
give it to just stop make it stop i'll
just sign it right
uh that's such good wisdom get a second
or third opinion
just slow down and uh make that call
alicia
that's what i would do i really would
too and get an opportunity to talk to
someone and let them know what's going
on
but all of the things he's suggesting
may have to occur but they might be able
to occur at a different
that's right increments that's right not
all at once
without the debt that's right and
there's all and and without the pain
that's yeah that's what i'm challenging
i just it's not logical to me so anyway
it might be wrong i'm not a dental
expert and i really don't even know what
i'm talking about
but i just have lived life a long time
and um
i usually smell fish when something's
fishy yeah
you still got all the same teeth every
one of them
that's impressive i've even got my
wisdom teeth which makes no sense at all
they never even came out seriously
it's crazy uh yeah well so
you know it just was wrong i mean you
know yeah this was wrong
and again but i like that get a second
or third opinion and again take notes
while you're in there
uh be aware uh but that's so true we get
pain going on we can easily get
emotional
i can't um and imagine if you're in with
a family member that you care about
it can be hard to recount some of the
things that are told to you so i had a
kidney stone one time i would have given
somebody a house to get rid of
you no i did have those when i was 10
and 11.
man i'm telling you you don't you're
just your mind is in a fog no i didn't
forget that i
i didn't miss when she said my teeth
hurt yeah
my tooth hurts i'm tired and she said it
in a way that like it's been hurting a
while and i'm tired of it yeah
and i understand that i appreciate that
i'm sorry yeah i i
that's how i would do it if i were in
your shoes and if you find
three people to tell you exactly the
same thing then you've got a different
challenge
but usually i find i make better
decisions the more options that i have
it's a decision-making tool
gather lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots of options
and the ones that suckle slide right
over to the side the other ones will
be you'll stick you know they'll stand
up right there and you'll go oh one of
those two is a really good idea that's
right
and uh but i often find if i have only
bad options i just don't have enough
options that's true
go back and gather more i like that and
that helps me with almost anything
especially things i don't know anything
about
i'm having to learn something new about
it you know and that's what i'm having
to do if i'm in her shoes there
so wow hey thank you for calling in
chris hogan good hour thank you sir
james childs and
kelly daniel in the booth great show
great hour that puts this hour of the
dave ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you're financially conscious you know
that healthcare expenses can take a big
bite out of your budget
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is here to help trim those expenses
and make sure your family is cared for
chm
is not health insurance but it is
christians helping
other christians by sharing each other's
medical bills
most people have the means to pay for
basic doctor services but
when it comes to something on a much
larger scale say
several thousand dollars for surgery or
hospitalization
folks are worried they'll be left to try
and find a way to pay for that
themselves
not too long ago i was diagnosed with
ovarian cancer
and they really came through so far
we've had over 180 thousand dollars
worth of bills
and got close to 75 percent in discounts
chm shared the rest of the expenses
to see if chm is right for you and your
budget
check out ch ministries
backslash budget
[Music]
my name is delaney baker i am a musician
in nashville
this is my wife tommy and this is our
story towards
debt freedom
[Music]
we got married fairly young i was right
out of college
and to say we were broke would be
an exaggeration we had no money what
happened three years and three months
ago that inspired this big change in
your life to get out of debt
[Music]
we both had separate checking accounts i
didn't know what he was bringing in
i didn't know how much money we made i
had no clue
she was working at a salon about the
time that i was
playing in a cover band that was doing
really well
i always had cash in my pocket we went
into that summer and it was like oh okay
that's fine you know and
i didn't watch where it went so it just
slipped through my fingers like water
the winter months are slow for a
musician
uh gigs kind of slow down uh
christmas break takes some of my
students so it was december of 2011 when
i realized that i didn't have money
to pay rent in january
and i don't think the stress that he was
feeling even
registered to me because
every time money was tight he would
always
find work it didn't click to me that we
were in trouble
she didn't know because we weren't
talking about it i was so
emotionally wrecked that i brought it
all to god
got down on my knees ugly cry
pull your heart out prayer and it was we
need to do this better we can do this
better
and i don't know what that looks like
yet but i'm open to
learning i hadn't felt the weight and
felt the pain
of the debt until that december you're
like okay god i need some help here
that's right and
he looks over at gabriel and goes hey
look that one woke up
so i reached out to a friend of mine
david stevenson
and asked him for his help sitting down
and doing
my taxes david said hey look we're
actually starting
an fpu class and we would like for you
guys to attend
folks chris hogan here do you feel like
you've tried everything to get your
finances in order
but you still can't get any traction
maybe you've tried budgeting
but life happened and you couldn't stick
with it or you've set goals to save and
invest
but can't get a hit because debt is
eating away at your paycheck
i've been there it's painful i'm gonna
be real with you okay
you already have the ability to build
wealth and find financial peace
inside of you you just need the right
coach
to help you get there people who work
with a coach
get results in fact they get fantastic
results
heck i even have a coach every success
story involves a coach someone cheering
you on
and offering guidance if you want to
continue to get the same results in your
financial life
keep doing the same thing but if you're
ready to win
get a financial coach it's the most
effective way to accomplish your
financial goals
and dreams how do i know i've spent over
a decade working as a financial coach
for dave ramsey's team
and here's what i found financial
coaching is all about helping you
make your financial dreams a reality
coaches aren't out to sell you
anything like investments or insurance
they help you understand what's holding
you back in your finances
build a plan to help you get to where
you want to be and
walk with you on your journey now here's
the good news
we have a network of trained financial
coaches
all across the country who are ready to
work with you
they're called ramsey preferred coaches
and they're the best at what they do
they seek to understand your specific
challenges
and help you build a tailored plan to
accomplish your
financial goals you hear that that voice
in your head
that makes you feel scared or vulnerable
that's the
same voice keeping you from reaching
your dreams
so tell it to shut up don't make excuses
make progress
if you want to be the best you have to
learn from the best
there's only one event that has it all
thousands of entree leaders
10 world-class speakers three
action-packed days
next year summit 2021
simon sinek patrick lincione marcus
buckingham
jim collins craig groeschel christy
wright
ken coleman john deloney chris hogan
and dave ramsey the difference between
those who lead and those who don't isn't
talent
leadership is a choice a choice you make
to go first
a choice to never settle for good enough
a choice
to never settle a choice to never stop
learning none of it is easy but the
answer is simple
entree leaders throw back their
shoulders and just leave
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
i want him to come clean out a credit
card that he doesn't know about
i am going to probably pay student loans
for the rest of my life i just don't
even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey show
you are not a victim you are the hero in
your story
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career everything just
started making sense i was like i'm
gonna
do this let's hear a debt-free scream
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
my co-host today here on the air chris
hogan ramsey personality number
one best-selling author couple times
over
the latest time on the book everyday
millionaires one of the largest studies
of millionaires ever done in north
america
and the results how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth and how you
can too
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five carrie is in athens
georgia
hi carrie welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi dave how are you great how can i help
i have a quick question um back in march
um uh we decided you know the stock
market was looking very very bad
and um we've always just saved all of
our our money into our 401k
for retirement well we decided at this
moment because
between the market going down so much
and
my my husband had lost his parents
it was just one of those very scary
times and so he took a bulk
of our money and put it into cash oh no
other fee
and so of course yeah so it's in cash
so he took a huge loss
he yeah
yeah oh i'm sorry yeah yeah
so how much cash have we got
well left in the market we have about
350.
and how much cash cashed
he said he took it out in cash he cashed
it out right
well i he moved it to cash okay inside
is 401k
yeah so there's 350 in the market
meaning still invested in mutual funds
and the other
is in cash and how much is in cash
um 900. oh god
yeah okay and so of course he expected
and it was you know at the time like i
said it was not something he would
normally do
i think it was a very emotional time
because he crossed his parents like i
said
um and so now um
you know he just how old are you
we're in our early 50s okay so what's
your question
so the question is okay so do we because
i do know
you know a little bit about real estate
and i have one home that's paid off
um and one has a mortgage do we take
the bulk of that now that that 900 and
just start
buying more investment property
if you take it out of your 401k you're
going to be taxed and penalized
yeah you're gonna give up 40 more
you're going to give half of it to the
government okay
i didn't think it was that much yeah
well i mean it's 30
tax rate plus a 10 penalty
right so it's another 400 grand is gone
i don't know i can't do that yeah yeah
that won't work
yeah and and and carrie here's one of
the things that happens
people get very like you said emotional
uh you start losing loved ones and
things start you you you hurt um but
yeah but
i'm i'm gonna advise you all to that
stop gap to have in there is to have a
professional to talk to
so you don't make the knee-jerk
reactions so investment professional
an investment professional this is a
counselor you you you all need to be
able to have someone that you can sit
and bounce ideas off of
and be given information back that truly
will help you
like not only do you all need an
investment professional you need a tax
professional now
uh to really start to look and
understand the estimated tax you're
gonna have in come april
no they're not gonna have it it's still
in the 401k you said right no
correct you have cashed it out just move
the money from mutual funds into cash
inside the 401k yeah yeah that's what i
thought
okay i misunderstood okay yeah so
you know it's a pretty simple thing
you're only 50. um
you've got another 15 or 20 years to
invest you made a mistake that cost you
probably three or four hundred thousand
dollars
correct correct and so i'm just going to
start investing
you need to move it out of cash into
mutual funds today
oh okay and just because what do you
think the
american economy is going to do in the
next 20 years regardless of democrats or
republicans
i have seen it grow in every single
20-year period
in modern day history
okay okay and so you got 20 years before
you're gonna need the money i'm sorry
what about bonds though i know that's
safe
no they're not okay no they're not you
know what happens to bonds when interest
rates go up
what's that bond prices go down they
have an inverse relationship with
interest rates where are interest rates
in comparison to the last 30 years
they're at rock bottom lows where are
they going to go from here
eventually up bond market is the
absolute worst place to be right now
okay so here's what you guys need you've
got to have to retrain your brains
you need to go what happened was you
made a
really bad decision
really bad and you need to undo that
decision
and you need data points
and historical data on mutual funds
that indicate to you that you made a
really bad decision
so that you don't do it again and that
will also give you confidence to invest
going forward
which you don't have because you just
told me you wanted to do bonds
right so you guys do whatever you want
to do if i were you i would sit down
with a pro what chris is telling you go
to daveramsey.com click on smart vester
and don't go over there to invest go
over there to learn
for a little while let's just gather up
some learnings
yeah and just go and let them just teach
you without
shaming you i'm not trying to shame you
but i'm trying to
but i am trying to convict you because
the the
conviction versus condemnation because
when i do something that's dumb and it
costs me money
and then i i have to have confidence in
the future
to not do the same thing or not stay on
the same track
and so what you're telling me by asking
me about bonds is you still don't trust
the stock market
over the next 20 years and i do and by
the way it's the only reasonable option
for your 900k right now because it's
inside of
a 401k and so put it in mutual funds
let it grow again and you just you just
and don't obsess like glance but don't
obsess over it like like it's
it's remember investing is long-term
it's going to be the roller coaster ride
you're going to have the ups and downs
but
i mean you can we can look inside of
this year with a pandemic at what the
market has done
and what it's doing right now and what
it's going to continue to do
so slow down kerry like dave said you
need to get somebody in your corner to
guide you
that you guys can sit and look at this
and go oh
this is how it works and this is the
expectation of what's to come next
and you'll get confident and you and
your husband will be able to breathe you
all have done an excellent job
of having money invested you've
intentionally put that money away
so i'm proud of what you've done now
let's get back on the course
back into the game so we can cross that
finish line young lady
you still got time you can do it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five trying to pull up
and get yeah there it is
wow yeah that's exactly what it did it
cost her 300 grand
i just pulled the chart up oh this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we got a plan of action together it was
so much fun
i started really meal planning and
couponing
and making laundry so
it was exciting to know that we could
work together at
a common goal so we were a year and a
half into
the plan 56 000 when we started so we
had paid off
25 000 at this point we were living
in a three-bedroom house
with a huge backyard paying rent to
my parents who own the place and we get
a call saying
your dad's job may be in jeopardy
we have to sell the house
i wanted to buy it my heart wanted to
buy it just
because we'd made it home it was a
heartbreaking yep
but on the other hand we're still 30
some thousand dollars in debt
if we moved into a much smaller
apartment and it was like a smack in the
face
it was reality setting in this
is what it means to be living within our
means we realized we were
very spoiled you've paid off 56
000 yeah what are the secrets to getting
out of debt
communication sitting down and doing the
budget we did it weekly
yes we did when we attended fpu we
realized the importance of sitting down
and doing a budget weekly and making
sure that we watched every penny
thursdays are our days off and we get up
and make coffee
and make a big breakfast we'll play
cards and then we'll sit down and get to
business
it became one of the sweetest times of
the week
just because we were living with an
irregular income
we could no longer use that as an excuse
what we gave up in order to
maintain our heading we look back at now
and i'm grateful it was a temporary pain
i never got a chance to take my wife on
a honeymoon
and so we're going to say about where to
go
hasn't always been easy and there have
been many uh dissonant moments where
we felt discouraged and defeated
but looking back those times were
essential to creating a deeper
appreciation
just how sweet and meaningful this verse
of our lives has been
and can't wait to start the next
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every step of
the way
just like they've helped thousands of my
listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
chris hogan ramsay personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
pulled up the charts at the break just
to review
the highest point the stock market has
been at in this calendar year in the
year 2020 known as the year of the
dumpster fire
the highest it was the dow was at twenty
nine thousand five hundred it's a
twenty nine thousand one hundred today
it dove all the way down to 17 000.
or 18 000. and so it lost
a third of its value from february 12th
to march 23rd so a month and 10 days
it dove straight off a cliff
and from that low on march the 23rd
which was
that was the shutdown week that's the
week things shelter at home
flattened the curve things we don't hear
anymore
no now they just yell wear a mask but um
you know it was flattened the curve
flattened the curve i hadn't heard flat
in the curve in a while no we haven't
so um the um
anyway side direct but the
uh uh uh but we sit down here now right
now
do i know where are we with the now 29
or 29 0001
so we're right at where we were right
back to where it was so if he had
if that guy you know so he sells out at
900 which cost him
approximately uh 350
000 in lost value between
march the uh i mean between uh february
12th and march 23rd
and then now here we sit in november
and it's back and you've recovered 99
of the value uh you would have broke
even
if you'd erode it out and we were you
and i were on the air march the 23rd
telling people yelling at the top of our
lungs the only people that get hurt on a
roller coaster are those
that jump off yep they go for safety
and the boy that's like a primo example
it is a primo
it really is i was just making notes of
that you begin to look at this and you
realize
oh and you know stomach in that right
doing the math on that
missing out on 350 000 i mean come on
right uh you know so get people in your
corner you can have a conversation with
so you can understand
what's happening and what you should do
here's the thing i when i was a kid i
was 16 years old i got a
1980 or 1974 monte carlo i did 36
500 miles on it between that time and
the time i graduated from college
driving that car
i put 200 000 miles on it two
transmissions and three engines
i was hard on a car and it was hit on
every side had bondo all over it
under the paint so i wore that car out
which means i know how to turn a wrench
because i had to be able to put the
muffler back on after it fell off i had
to be able to
whatever i changed the transmissions and
the engines out you know i did
everything when i had to
so i know how to turn a wrench but you
know what i have a nice
new corvette in my garage the chances of
me lifting the hood
and even knowing what it is going on
under there
much less actually putting a wrench on
that thing are
zero yeah not gonna happen yeah i do not
diy on that car
don't diy on your investments it's good
sit down with a pro i have dave ramsey
has chris hogan
everyday millionaires chris hogan has a
smart vester pro in our corner
and if we need something if we're scared
if we're going through a hard time
we call them yep and talk it through you
do not need to add
unnecessary stress in your life you do
not want someone making your decisions
for you but you need a coach in your
corner that says
no don't run out of bounds that's right
matter of fact i'm going to be reaching
out to one of the tax elps
as soon as we get done here today just
to double check some stuff for year in
and start to do some planning
and so it's this mindset of don't let
your pride get in the way of your
progress
uh again talk to people that have
knowledge that you don't that's what
smart people do listen if you're worried
about the biden
presidency if you're worried about the
pandemic
if you're worried about the future you
need to sit down and get some
perspective by looking at history listen
to this text the word invest
to 33 789 invest two three
three seven eight nine and uh we'll
connect you up with one of the
smartvestor pros
we're not in that business but let me
just tell you man you don't diy i don't
diy that new corvette
i'm not doing it that just would be
silly
joshua's in phoenix hey joshua how are
you
good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so i recently graduated college uh back
in may
and i recently found uh your podcast
around a month ago and i'm currently on
baby step two
great um i have around 36 000 in debt
um 9 000 of which is a car loan
and 27 000 in student loans
i just wanted your advice on how to
tackle this
um i was thinking about selling that car
um i can sell it for around 14 to 15 000
um or just paying that 9 000 off um and
also
paying off my student loans yeah that's
what i would do what do you make what's
your income
uh i make around um pre-tax eight
thousand a month
oh you're killing it man i would keep
that car you don't need to move down a
car
but you do need to get on a written
budget and completely lean in
and do nothing with money but pay off
debt
hard and fast fast as you can like your
life depended on it
okay so i do have thirty thousand in
savings oh good write a check and pay it
off
uh pay off the car pay off pay off the
car and put the rest of it on the
student loan down to a thousand dollars
because you only have 35 or 36 000 in
debt
and so you're gonna be out of debt like
three months two months
okay um so let me recap let me recap
the shortest the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealth is debt free
and that's why i'm doing this it feels
herky-jerky to you and you're in love
with your 30 000
savings account so this when i just said
this your head just spun around twice
right yeah okay so
but knowing what i know
having lived as long as i've lived and
as many people as i've gotten out of
debt and
taught him how to be wealthy and me
included and chris included
we know that we as fast as we possibly
can need to get rid of the debt
and then very quickly rebuild your
emergency fund you need three to six
months of expenses emergency fund you
make eight
thousand dollars a month okay
you're in good shape man you're killing
it what's your career
i'm in uh mortgage okay good you're
doing great
so here's the thing you pay off the car
and we put 20 and we and we put i see
you said you had 30 is it actually
exactly 30 000 that you have
um i have around uh 30 000
and 500. okay good all right so baby
step one is a thousand dollars i want
you to leave a thousand dollars in there
which gives us twenty nine thousand
five hundred right
okay that pays off nine thousand dollar
car that leaves me twenty thousand and
five hundred which means you have six
thousand five hundred left on your
student loan does that sound right to
you
yeah if you do that if you follow that
through and then you're gonna do that
this afternoon if i'm you
okay okay so just leave a thousand leave
a thousand and there's your little baby
starter emergency fund now making eighty
eight thousand dollars and you only got
6 500
in debt i would expect you to pay that
debt off within two months wouldn't you
two months yeah that's definitely
something i can do
3 200 a month and you're done then
i want you to save four or five thousand
dollars a month
into that thousand dollar account baby
step three and let's start raising
this back up now walk through the math
with me here for a second
thousand dollars has got your stomach in
your throat
right yeah definitely month one
it's still there but now you got month
two it's still there but now you got
zero debt
and no payments you still with me
yeah month three you're gonna put
four thousand dollars into that account
and you're gonna have five thousand
dollars
ninety days from today month four
you following this yeah you're gonna
have another four thousand dollars so
now you're gonna be at
roughly ten thousand dollars in this
account four months from today you're
going to be a hundred percent debt free
with ten thousand dollars in the account
does that feel a little bit better
that does i think uh what initially held
me back was just seeing all that
savings yeah because it feels like it's
forever and my point is it's
only for four months five months is
fifteen
six months is twenty seven months is you
know
eight months from today you're gonna
have thirty thousand dollars and no
there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
once you are completely debt free except
for your house
the next step is baby step three and
that is getting
three to six months of expenses saved in
the bank so question i get asked a lot
is like well should we have like
three months of expenses or should be
like more like
six and like it doesn't really matter
wherever you want to go
and i'll be honest it's funny usually a
lot of men
land at like the three month mark like
once they get three months they're like
all right let's move on baby step four
a lot of women are like oh i like to be
more around the six month mark
women's number one financial fear is the
lack of
security so naturally they're going to
lean more towards the six month i know i
do
we actually have an emergency fund for
our emergency fund because i just want
to make sure
we have a ton in savings it just makes
me feel better so i
personally lean more towards six
winston's probably most guys
he'd probably lean more towards three
but whatever you want to do now again
these expenses are your operating
expenses
this is not you you know budgeting okay
if i want to go on a huge
fashion shopping spree or we're going to
go on vacation no no
you're operating expenses like what is
the amount of money you need to have
to keep the lights on to keep food on
the table to keep things
operating like they would be otherwise
that is what
the emergency fund is for it's there in
case of a job loss
it's there in case of a medical
emergency whatever comes
up that is unexpected in a big emergency
this fund is there to catch you it's
like your
major safety net between you and life
and you have to think of this as
insurance
not an investment say it with me
through your phone or computer insurance
not
an investment you're gonna get a pile of
money
saved in the bank and some of you out
there gonna be like oh my gosh
we could invest this and make so much
more money it's just sitting there like
making nothing
listen that is what it is for you have
to think of this as insurance because
you want to be able
to keep it liquid you want to be able to
get to it quickly
so i would recommend having this in a
money market account or even you could
do
a traditional savings account but it
needs to be there
so that you can get to it quickly i went
to my facebook community
and i found some people that are in baby
step
three and this is what they said it
feels like my worries dissipated because
of no debt life and the fact i was able
to accomplish baby step two
on schedule losing extra overtime to
spend with my kids
doesn't bother me anymore that was the
very surprising experience
i had i listen to the podcast every day
write on my journal do my budget
religiously and being
intentionally positive 98 of the time
single mom of two here and it can be
done
melrose you're killing it such a great
job tiffany said we stayed motivated by
sacrificing a lot so that we could see
a lot of progress being made quickly we
looked at our budget often and
forecasted when we would get the next
ten
thousand dollars paid off and when we
would be completely
debt free it feels great knowing that we
were on our way to building wealth now
instead of just paying for bad decisions
guys baby step three it is possible
it is possible and could you just sit
there and imagine having no debt
and having three to six months of
expenses saved in
the bank incredible it puts you at a
completely
different place mentally and financially
it's so great
you can do this
[Music]
hey guys george campbell here with
another minute money hack
i'm here at cody's automotive in
franklin tennessee and i'm super revved
up to talk about car hacks today
now i know what you're thinking what
does george know about cv joint boost
intake manifold gaskets and
clutch pack pistons well i know less
than you think
that's why i have friends like cody hey
cody here's how this works i'm going to
start the clock
and we're going to take this thing from
0 to 60 seconds and well 60 seconds
let's do it here we go don't over pay
for gas you can download a smartphone
app like gasbuddy to find the cheapest
gas near
you also you can use a gps app like waze
or google maps to avoid traffic jams and
find the best routes while you're at it
some shops will repair your tire for
free regardless of where you bought it
speaking of tire pressure your
recommended tire pressure is actually in
your door jam usually it's around 32 psi
i like to run mine around 34
35 you'll get a little better fuel
economy that way too
clean your teeth and your headlights
with the same product good old-fashioned
toothpaste just rub some on a damp cloth
and put a little elbow grease in it i
like to use lemon pledge it works great
and it smells good too
use an app like retailmenot to find
great deals on oil changes near you
a lot of shops lose money on oil changes
so don't get sucked into unnecessary
repairs
don't overpay for car insurance connect
with an endorsed local provider in your
area they shop the top companies to find
you
the best rates and thanks to cody at
cody's automotive any time george
and there's your minute money hack
it's an honor to tell you about the army
national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage one of our
own ramsey solutions family members team
members here
ashley kraft is with us she's one of the
creative
recruiters that doesn't mean that she's
creative
as a recruiter it means she recruits
creatives
she probably is creative as a recruiter
though too so and
her husband joshua welcome guys thank
you
so how long have you been with us i've
been working at ramsey for
about a year and a half okay cool cool i
thought it was about that amount of time
just verify that so how much debt have
you guys paid off
we've paid off 169 thousand dollars 156.
wow and how long did that take just
under three years
three years okay and i won't ask your
income since you work here
and half of your teammates are standing
around completely unfair
but what kind of debt was the 169
uh pretty much everything we had car
loans student loans credit cards
iphone payments on att everything kind
of normal
just anything we wanted we bought it and
had a payment yeah that made you normal
how long you guys been married
uh four and a half years yeah almost
five okay so you're married a couple of
years
and something happens and you went i'm
getting out of this mess tell me about
it
yeah so i mean it's really just when
we're dating we think we're gonna
combine our incomes and just be set
you know we're gonna have double the
income and six months in we were broke
and i mean just every week it was
checking our bank account can i
buy at the grocery store you know can i
get gas today or do i need to wait till
tomorrow and it just
wasn't working for us and really just
kind of hit that point where
we had to change it yeah so what'd you
do
so actually i was listening to the
podcast my brother introduced me and
oh to mine okay and uh kind of started
thinking about it and visiting my family
i found an old
old cd fpu kit wow and from like i don't
know 15 years ago the leather one with
all the
the leather one yeah yeah leather it
wasn't real leather leather
right yes so i brought it home and uh i
was nervous to talk to her about it i
didn't know how she'd feel but i love
i'm the spender i'm the free spirit
yeah so we listened to it on a car trip
straight all nine lessons and uh
i mean we were on board from then wow
okay yeah
so you you have the stress point and
you're like and then
the cds come along so um
actually at what point on this car trip
what were you listening to
when you went i think where you need to
do this well it was actually beforehand
so when he brought that fpu kit home
from
maryville tennessee which is where he
visited his dad um
he brought it home and he was nervous to
tell me and he came and he said
are you sick and tired of being sick and
tired and broke i was like yes and
so we went downstairs and for the first
time ever totaled up all of our debt and
really it it heart it was heartbreaking
to see
and so at that point it was the moment
where i knew we either do something
drastic or we're going to be in this for
the rest of our lives
and so that heartbreaking moment was
really when i said
i am the free spirit but i want to be a
free spirit later with money
and be able to serve differently and
give differently and um we have a
uh 11 week old and so we just wanted to
change our family tree for our daughter
as well
yeah fantastic yeah and so it
it wasn't hard once i saw that number
and once i had a plan once i have a plan
i can get on board
it's kind of the process where you have
the oh crap moment yes and then you go
okay something's got to give yeah and
that's that there's a
i think there's a moment there where we
all grow up
and you just go oh yeah i gotta change
this yeah yeah
for us it was a three-hour silent period
where we just kind of stared at the
numbers
and we just didn't know what to do you
wait on them to shrink yeah
and they don't yes yes and this can't be
real
i married into most of our debt too a
lot of it was his student loans and he
didn't have his degree yet
and so it's really hard for me as his
new wife to accept
that he has all the student loan debt he
doesn't even have his degree
like this is ridiculous and so it was a
moment for us to
accept what we've done and i had some of
it as well
but for me to really say we're going to
tackle this together and i still love
you but
this is something we have to tackle
together so when you're recruiting a
creative do you talk about your personal
story at all
oh a hundred percent also yes um so i
mean getting somebody
a creative to come to work on our team
someone in our one of our
many creative positions that we have
around here
so um and because you're you're
responsible for hiring four or five
people a month aren't you
yes roughly yeah okay wow
so this uh this this is it's really come
i mean and then you come over here
halfway through your get out of debt
journey and come to work here
yes how's this happen tell me about that
yeah so part way through um our our
journey actually
really closer to the beginning um josh
worked like four or five
super random jobs i decided to start a
calligraphy and design business
and so i am a creative and
really i was working a job that i
absolutely hated but i had to work
because we had so much debt and i
couldn't do anything except work
and um so for me part way through our
debt free journey i
didn't want to hate every day i wanted
to thrive in what i was doing and so i
decided
i'm going to find work that i love right
now and i'm going to find a job that
really makes an impact and honestly this
is the only place i wanted to work so i
applied
um accepted the job and we absolutely
love it here
very cool very cool so you guys moved
here yep from louisville kentucky
okay all right cool and uh what do you
do joshua
i work at schneider electric oh yeah
okay very good
yeah excellent well way to go all right
now you've done it your heroes
169 000 uh
what is the secret to getting out of
debt
for me it was just kind of just being
able to go to work
really was the first one and then not
caring what people think you know you
really have to swallow your pride when
you sell your nice car and you start
driving to work you know just a piece of
junk
and you know just knowing that people
are seeing you seeing the changes you're
making and just being okay with that
so that was mine yeah i think i
mentioned it earlier but just
really accepting the fact that we did
this and you have to really look
yourself in the mirror and that's the
hardest part is
to kind of forgive yourself for all the
mistakes that you made and realize
we we need to get out of this but that's
that's a hard part and then again i'm
the free spirit so i love spending money
so saying no to yourself is really hard
but i think keeping your why
front and foremost um one of the things
that we did all the time was we had
dream dates and so we'd go out to dinner
um and we would or we'd make dinner and
we would just talk about
what is our why to keep that front and
center um that was really important to
us and we loved our dream dates
so yeah that's really neat joshua what'd
you find out about this young lady
throughout this journey
she is really just unstoppable
if she puts her mind to it there's
nothing she can't do i mean she started
her business
and just really seeing us being through
this whole process just seeing how
just she can just do anything that's
awesome ashley what about you what'd you
learn about joshua
uh he loves excel spreadsheets and i
hate them
he is our nerd and i love him because i
don't think like that and
i come to our budget meetings but i hate
them unless there's like a category for
bows for our daughter
something cute so that makes me happy
very fun very fun all right are you
going to put everly in the shot here
let's add her in there so way to go you
guys we're so proud of you we got a copy
of chris's book but you probably already
have one
uh you're definitely in the next chapter
here to be everyday millionaires
and how old is everly now she is 11
weeks 11
weeks oh my gosh just barely holding it
there we go
yeah that's good she just screamed i'm
dead free i heard
she's better now that's awesome all
right
joshua and ashley and everly 169
000 paid off in three years count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two
[Music]
11 weeks old and screaming debt-free is
pretty cool i don't care what you say
be the youngest one ever right there i
think it might be it really
at least on the stage in front of us yes
somebody might have had one in the
background at their home or something
but um well listen i can tell you
front
the team members and people that she's
impacted recruited and worked with
uh being out to celebrate uh this place
ramsey solutions is a different place
um and it's this is displayed when you
see team members smiling from here to
here grinning
rooting for another team member who's
crossed the finish line
that's something special people
absolutely special
absolutely good family well done you
guys we're so proud of you
well done i love it this
is the dave ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've been lied to we've been told that
debt is normal
credit cards are a must and stressing
over money
is just how it is financial peace
university was created to help
everyday people just like you take
control of their money
fpu coordinators are the reason that
financial peace university
has reached over 6 million people
helping them overcome the lies
dump debt and change the course of their
financial future forever
you can start helping people today
regardless of your experience with
financial peace university
after you've signed up to become a
volunteer coordinator there are three
steps we will walk you through
first you'll set up your class just pick
a location at a time that works for you
you can lead in any public space your
local church
your home or even online whenever you're
ready
just set up your class through your
digital account our team can help you
decide which option
is right for you next invite people
once you're set up spread the word to
your friends and neighbors
if your class is public people can
search for it online
or you can keep it private and only
invite people you know
we'll even help you get the word out
with a ton of resources to promote your
class
finally just start meeting your class
members will watch video lessons
taught by our team of financial experts
then you'll facilitate
group discussions and encourage members
on their journey ahead
you can either watch the video lessons
together or have members watch
lessons on their own before meeting for
group discussions
your account comes with everything you
need to lead and manage your class with
confidence
stream video lessons take training
courses send messages to class members
access lesson guides and much more
here's the best part
leading a class is completely free with
the included digital leader materials
if you want to purchase physical
materials just sign in to your
coordinator dashboard for exclusive
product discounts look
you don't have to be a money expert to
be a coordinator
you don't have to be debt free you don't
even have to take the class before
leading one
all you need is a desire to help people
learn the truth
that there is a proven plan for them to
take control
and win with their money come join us
and volunteer to be a coordinator today
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept of
christians sharing each other's burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian healthcare ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the health care law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
healthcare needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
[Music]
our scripture of the day james 1 17
every good gift and every perfect gift
is from above
coming down from the father of lights
with whom there is narrow
variation or shadow due to change
[Music]
the dalai lama said remember that not
getting what you want is sometimes a
wonderful
stroke of luck open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five chris hogan is my
co-host today here on the air
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
daniel is in winston-salem hi daniel how
are you
hey dave and chris it's uh good to get
to talk to you guys you too what's up
um i was calling um i have questions
about long-term disability
insurance um me and my life is on uh
we're gonna be in baby step four next
month
um and i'm the sole income provider
i've started having some vision issues
that could potentially be the start of
heading into blindness potentially but
we don't know that yet i visited one
doctor and he's sending me to a
specialist but i haven't had a diagnosis
yet so my question is
would it be immoral to go and try to get
long-term disability insurance at this
moment knowing that i'm having these
these symptoms and also if i could get
long-term disability insurance what
should i look out for when i buy it
most of them are going to ask medical
questions and you would have to lie
on the medical question which would be
not only immoral it'd be called fraud
um but the uh if you don't lie and
you have a long-term disability policy
that you can apply for that does not
require a medical screening or medical
questionnaire
then that's fine do they have long-term
disability through your work
i'm a realtor so i don't have uh there
may be one there may be some through the
real
uh through the national association of
realtors okay
sometimes there's like uh uh association
group plans and things
i would check on that and again all
you've got to do is to tell the truth
right and if it's if it's if it does not
require a medical then it doesn't
require medical you haven't done
anything wrong
uh but obviously uh or i guess i should
say obvious
maybe it's not obvious to everybody but
obviously to me you should not
and to you probably you should not lie
on the thing because it's
a it's wrong and b it's called fraud so
and and you know it'd be undone
if you lied because they'll come back
and say well you had this
diagnosis ahead of time and you would
you know you would lose the
coverage anyway what you look for the
main things to remember are just
um if you can get inflation kickers that
kick it kick the inflation
kick the uh income up due to inflation
every so often
that's one thing to look for another is
you want to know what your elimination
period is
which is your same as your deductible
that's exactly right and that's the
amount that you have to pay before the
insurance kicks in
and so that elimination period is a very
crucial word and you want to be aware of
it
yeah so is it a 90-day elimination
period meaning from the time of
disability
disability is declared that's right
until you get money would be 90 days
and by the way 90 days is a fairly
standard elimination period that's kind
of like a 500
deductible on a car or something like
that that's what you would expect to see
30 days is highly unusual and usually
much more expensive
and six months if you can get that might
save you on the premiums
if you can if you can get the policy so
those are the main things you're going
to want to look for
but in your case i think you've got a
lot more things to worry about than the
actual
policy features yeah it's just whether
or not you can get one issued or not
yeah and then you'll do like dave said
definitely check with the national
association of realtors
to find out what group benefits you have
available but please my friend
also get a second and third opinion uh
so you can really find out
exactly what it is you're dealing with
and you're down in north carolina
so that's a a cradle for fantastic uh
care down there but make sure you're
getting to a specialist so you
understand
you're awfully young to be dealing with
a challenge like that my friend so
my prayers go out to you and your family
amen yeah amen tyler is up next
and tyler is in missoula montana hi
tyler how are you
hey dave and chris great to speak to you
both you too what's up
awesome um i'm 22. uh just started baby
step four and um i've decided to go to
the university here
get the four year and then go to the law
school and just cash flow it
good um so i'm curious if i should
one uh stop investing um
for my retirement and two um
if i should treat this more like baby
step three like kind of
um because it's gonna be future debt you
know
um kind of trying to attack that before
it happens yeah
yes i would stop investing and just pile
up cash as high as you can pilot
so that you can get through school debt
free and if you do that you are a better
investment than a mutual fund is
yup okay and tyler will you be working
while you're going to undergrad
yeah yeah i'm an independent contractor
that's fantastic
yeah yeah buddy you will give yourself
more and more options
the more debt that you can avoid even
with law school
and i mean i want you to bust it in the
summers
uh and really understand that hey you
are going to avoid a heartache and
headache
i know some attorneys that have had some
legal debt hanging around for 15 and 20
years
so the more of that that you avoid the
better off you're gonna be
yeah you're gonna you're gonna not
regret a moment of that not at all
if you pay cash all the way through and
you save that up
and cash flow this that is a huge
accomplishment be very proud of you
sandra's in indianapolis hi sandra
welcome to the dave ramsey show how can
we help
hi hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure
um i have a bit of a dilemma i want your
advice on
we attempted to refinance our mortgage
we started the process in august
we have a balloon payment that matured
on
at the end of september and we're trying
to get that
refi done in time and they say it was
fine to do it
um they dragged everything
sorry i'm very nervous um end of last
september or this coming september
this uh this last september
so you're overdue on the on the bloom
payment by two now
exactly we're overdue now because they
delayed and delayed and i kept calling
trying to
hurry the process up and they kept
having excuses and now they're saying
they can't do the reply they've declined
us now
why because um we were overdue
sandra what was the reason they gave you
for the decline
the initial reason they gave us was
because they can't do a refinance once
the balloon payment has become due okay
you need to you need to go to a
different mortgage company
you're trying to work with your existing
mortgage company right mm-hmm
right yeah you need to run away from
them and should have like yeah
we want to run away from them yeah the
problem is though that now we're showing
as defaulted is this going to affect our
credit i mean
it may we're not late it may it may
what's the house worth the house is
worth 235
thousand dollars and what do you owe on
the mortgage
we a hundred and seventeen thousand okay
you've got tons of equity you're gonna
be okay is there a heloc or second
mortgage on this property
no there's a second mortgage but we were
we're going to pay that off how much is
the second
okay how much is the second mortgage oh
it's like 13 000
how much cash do you have we have about
25 yeah and do you have investments that
are not retirement investments
we do not know they're all 401k how much
is in your 401k
uh probably about 130
or somewhere there okay all right here's
our scenario
number one you got to breathe because
you're really scared and you don't need
to be
you don't need to be scared you don't
need to be scared because the only time
i cash out a 401k is to avoid a
foreclosure
yeah and so you're not going to get
foreclosed on worst case scenario is
your cash out your 401k put 25k with it
and you're going to pay off the house
that's your worst case scenario you're
not going to do that
but that keeps you from losing the house
with all this equity and we'll start
again fresh
okay now what you do when you hang up i
want you to call churchill mortgage
that we've endorsed for 20 plus years on
this show
25 years on this show and uh
i tell you what better than that i'm
gonna put you on hold and kelly is gonna
pick up and she's gonna
hand you white glove to churchill
mortgage
and get this solved for her tell
churchill i said get this solved
and i bet you they can do it i bet you
they can walk matter of fact hank just
walked in and he can make that happen
so you got to be careful when you walk
in the booth right at the end of the
show
there you go good job chris thank you
sir good job to james and to uh kelly
there in the booth
i am dave ramsey your host we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
[Music]
so
people call my show all the time
complaining
about how awful their time shares are
and yet you guys have been really having
good success getting people
out of their timeshares we have we kind
of helped create this industry
now there's a lot of exit companies out
there they come and they go
timeshare extra team is different i mean
we we now have
you know almost 20 000 people out of
timeshare contracts
actual results actual results big deal
our guarantee is that if we can't get
you out of your timeshare
we give you your money back hey if you
need out
timeshare exit team is the team
the only team that i trust to help you
schedule your free consultation by
calling 844
999 exit or
[Music]
timeshareexitteam.com
[Music]
[Music]
you